do you plan to own a movie studio one
day
um great question yes i do um it's been
a
childhood dream and it's become more of
a reality with so many independent
people being able to do that and
accomplish it
um so yes that is i have a big dream for
the team i'm working with
and building that team up to be big
enough to need
its own studio so that's the goal to
build an infrastructure
um uh enough projects to funnel through
to that studio be in use and then also
offer that for
independents like me that don't have
that opportunity to give them that
opportunity just like another studio did
for us
in in a lot of different projects we've
worked on so when you were a little girl
you were thinking about having
movies like how does that work most of
the girls want to be little princesses
or they're playing
you know absolutely yeah i um i liked
theater
theater was like wow and it wasn't even
i can't say not real theater but i
started in church theater
but i just love that an audience
i remember the moment i looked out and
the audience was like captivated
and i was like this is i want that i
want that
and it wasn't the i it never for some
reason didn't really apply so much to
acting but i just wanted to create that
for people
where they could see something and they
could feel something from it
and it wasn't even real it's art so i
was attracted to that
so it started with a theater type
mindset but then i went to film because
i watched so many movies
my parents didn't let us watch a lot
they were pretty strict so
auntie's house whoever they would let me
watch movies and i was just like
captivated by it so i was like i can do
this too
like so it's very childlike uh mindset
on it
but then you find out other little
pieces like oh people have movie studios
because i would watch
old movies i was singing in the rain was
my favorite movie growing up so
then i'm like studios look at this a big
set with like
uh ladders and things i was like i want
that
so now it's a real dream a real goal
but before it was just a fantasy
i think i read where you said you were
okay being behind the scenes
which is just interesting just because
you're beautiful
you would think that you'd want to be an
actress or
that people would have you know given
you a lot of compliments
and you're okay with being behind the
scenes can you talk about that yeah i
love i love being behind the scenes it's
my favorite place to be
um it really it comes down to um
knowing that leadership was a was a
strength of mine growing up
and not that an actor or someone in
front of the scenes can't be a leader
but there's a limitation to your
leadership you're you're leading through
inspiration you're not leading through
here's a job
here's an opportunity let me help build
your life up let me
show you how great you are it's a harder
thing for someone that's in front of the
camera someone that is out there
to look like something or to be a piece
um
a use a piece that someone uses and
that's in any industry like a basketball
player i would want to be the owner you
know
because then i get to hire them and help
them be better men or whatever it is
like
that was my thought process with that i
behind the scenes i saw
my skill set could be an actor but then
i could use
all of my skill sets behind the scenes
yeah interesting
okay also too you put yourself out there
there's going to be more
hits coming your way so it seems like
sometimes it's
more creatively freeing to be behind the
scenes i don't know maybe i'm just oh
yeah
being behind the scenes is creatively
freeing and then also you have a sense a
better sense of power
um for me and i speak a lot of this to
actors that i know
i'm like i could never do what you do
because they their their
craft they build it in such a beautiful
way and then they have to wait for
someone to tell them yes
that's hard and i'm a very uh east coast
kind of girl like i go after things very
aggressively so for me to be dependent
on just a yes or no
which we always have to be dependent on
that in some way in life but it's like
at least i can like do
a lot of things that can create content
and things that has nothing to do with
someone else telling me
i like what you're doing i do that first
and then try to build it in a way that
they would like it
so we can sell it or show it or whatever
but at least we have that power and
lose using that word loosely but that
power we can make decisions and move
and then get someone to say yes because
they like what we made rather than the
other way around
have you thought about what this movie
studio will look like like will it be
you in one state and then you can
contract out to others like how does
this work yeah i would love to have a
studio
um on the east coast and i was
um i was inspired by the west coast
studios and
then the east coast studios there was
always something lacking or
maybe wasn't everyone brought together
in a certain way so the studio
that i foresee in my in our future would
be
um a place where you can go and do any
type of film any so we will have every
type of lot every type of stage
downstage is what may be long
very long and very high but also on the
side of like
housing for actors um crew whatever
um i want to have a um like an apartment
style place
right there instead of them having to go
to a hotel they can just stay right
there
houses built that we could use for
filming as well
um and then if we were filming something
more so
on the sound stage one of those houses
could be used for say the director and
his family because i think
something that really discourages me
about the business and then and whenever
you're discouraged you have to then
figure out how to be encouraged by it by
an action you can do
don't just stay in a discouraged place
um is that family structure is really
difficult in the entertainment industry
we know this but
we can change that it doesn't have to be
an accepted fact like angelina jolie
like she was like wow my kids are going
to set you have to hire me you have to
bring in a
area where they could be all day got it
but imagine the power of someone that
owns a studio
to say your family can come you your
kids can see you after you're off set
you can bring your mom
you can bring whoever and they're
totally disconnected it's not like the
family will be on set
but then you can go back to a place
where you can get centered for the
evening and i think actually
performers and crew would actually
perform better and then the ultimate
goal would be the family structure is
held intact
while still getting to pursue your
dreams you don't want to leave your
family for a month
bring them with you or at least let them
come visit
i know you had said in another interview
about
the interviewer asked you about how do
you stay balanced which is such a great
question and i know women
especially are told to focus on that
because they are
usually more uh you know the primary
sort of caregiver for the child
and you said just accept the fact there
is no balance yeah i think it's it's
really important um
our goals we're taught to they find that
perfect balance and
everything will become peaceful in your
life
but what if you never find it then
you're not peaceful like we can find
peace in
imbalance as long as we have priority
priority is more important to me than
balance because if i have my priorities
straight
i'm not going to lose my sense of peace
if my son is okay i have peace
my husband's okay i have peace so within
building an empire or
going forth against your to get your
dreams keep in mind your priorities and
you won't
have that disconnected loss of peace
while getting success you can have them
all if you focus on priority
versus balance for me that's that's
worked better yeah
so part of the studio would be to have a
place where the family could be there if
they wanted to
absolutely and then that balance sort of
falls into line maybe a little more
yeah i think it's important that we
don't just put the onus
on the uh the talent the crew
to hey figure it out you're working for
me for 12 hours today
for the next 30 days figure it out i
think we can actually provide some sense
of
we actually care too and i've seen it
with corporations it's not a new idea
um corporations do it they have family
day et cetera it's like
we can't disconnect because we're
entertainers and we're in this different
kind of world
we're in a different kind of world but
we're still in the world we still have
families
we still have a mom we still have
whatever it is that
life issues that we deal with so unions
are set in place to help with some of
that
on the side of life issues but it's a
it's a big gap
with someone that depends on what's
provided right now in the industry to
what they need for their life
and not just their career so i think
there's there's a way to do both while
still being very profitable
and not having a strain on the
production you touched on family
structure family dynamics earlier
were your parents encouraging of you
being in the entertainment industry
my parents were not at all encouraging
to the industry
they were adamantly no
i'm a child of foreigners immigrants
from jamaica my dad and you know he came
to this country
with a very specific dream to make a
better opportunity for
himself of course but his children so he
came here and not too long later he had
me and my brothers
so you get a job you get benefits you
build
like the american dream that he had in
his mind of what it is
i grew up here though i saw other dreams
in america that could be accomplished so
i had a totally different idea of that
and also i'm the
kind of the i guess unconventional one
in the family
when it comes to structure so i was just
always that problem child that would not
follow this beaten path like
okay stay here and i'm like what's over
there you know so
um no they were not supportive now
they're very supportive um so i would
encourage anyone dealing with that like
where
family is maybe causing an extra layer
of stress because they don't agree
or believe in what your your dreams are
it's okay
i think a really good book for that is
called um uh the dream giver
it goes on a journey and and the person
experiences a lot of that and it shows
you
that's fine they're just not going to
understand this moment but they're not
coming from a negative space and i think
if someone told me that early on
it would have been so much easier just
to say i respect your opinion and then
continue to move rather than
why are they so hateful towards me why
won't they like
respect and support my dreams it's like
it's okay they're worried about you
they care about you they know what's
best for you in their own limited way
so it's okay if you saw another way it's
okay if you see an expanded way but
respect their their disagreement and
then
go about your way with the confidence
that what you have in you that dream
was put there with a purpose and you're
going to achieve that dream if you don't
let that discourage you
how did you show them that this is what
you wanted to do and you still love them
and you still you're glad maybe that
they're worried for you but this is
who you are how did you show them that
um i think i showed them
it by not quitting um i quit a lot of
things as a little kid
and i really think that's because i was
i'm a very like definitive person
so if i've already decided what i want
to do and i start something else i'm not
going to be
happy about it so like i'll pick i'll
play the trumpet
you know like no quit it like oh i'll go
out for this quit it you know
um things like that so they didn't see
they would think oh she's gonna go on
this road and maybe quit
you know there were things that showed
them i don't stick to things other than
this
why would that be the thing so if i'm so
dedicated to that one thing or dedicated
to
you know success in school or something
you pick one or the other they went to
school it's like go to college get this
degree and then go off and have this
particular career so i show them by
sticking to what
i said that i wanted to do and i think
sometimes people just need to be proven
wrong
and do it by your actions not by your
words so i stopped arguing i didn't
you know keep saying look what i did and
i didn't even keep them posted on a lot
of things
i kept them posted when things happened
that i knew that would mean something to
them
from a limited perspective so it's like
hey i just got hired to aid the
feature film are you getting paid yup
i'm getting paid
rather than telling him the one i did
that i wasn't paid for you know so it's
like you don't have to keep them
up to date in your journey because
that's going to cause frustration
they're not going to be excited about it
but when something happens where you
feel like okay
this is a moment in time that i can
share and
still don't be dependent on their
reaction but they might have a good
reaction to this let me go ahead and
share it
i think that's the best way to handle
that that family uh
pushback on your career do you think
also because the last
decade in the united states and other
parts of the world
we've seen that that like safe route
isn't necessarily safe
that's good um yeah i think it's
becoming
far more clear now than say 20 years ago
that there are other ways people are
starting businesses while they're
having jobs and things like that but
also i think
i think there's fear involved whenever
someone's very cautious there is a fear
element to it
and identifying what the fear is i think
for my dad he grew up in
a family that was very wealthy in
jamaica and he watched them lose their
wealth
like drastically like it was like a
drastic thing they owned
horse track races and real estate and um
not the whole family but
the part that he was in they lost their
money and it caused a huge strain it was
caused a lot of problems for him and
childhood so that fear
that he was coming from was real but it
wasn't going to happen in my life
because i had him as a father
so i think um once he started to trust
that
he gave me something that i'm applying
in a different way
then that shows him i can make it
because he gave me the work ethic
he showed me to work hard um he gave me
integrity like
always treat people the way you want to
be treated and then some you know
be honest all those things that i got
from him i just applied it in different
arena
so yeah i think um just kind of seeing
what you know is truth applied
differently can help expand people's
minds too
yeah so when they say like the the child
always kind of does the opposite of what
the parent wants when you saw
that your father for very good reason
was fearful did that make you have like
more let's say bravery did that make you
almost want to prove
that fear wrong that's interesting um i
never thought of it
as i was trying to prove him wrong um it
might have been something in there
because when you said that it kind of
connected it might have been some of
that in there
behind the scenes but i think my
brothers they went on a
more traditional route in their careers
they kind of followed that a little
differently but
um followed it um but i think for me
i would say what i can agree with on
that end is
i know my dad and other people that i
know that were
more in a traditional way had other
dreams and to see them later in life
now trying to fit those them into their
lives it's much more difficult
to do it later it can be it's very
possible mary kay did it and so many
others
but um it's harder because you already
have such a way established
i knew that i couldn't like do what he
said like well just do this and then go
back to that well that's what you did
and i couldn't say that to him like dad
that doesn't work but
i saw him do that and i saw maybe a
certain discontentment with certain
things that would have been different if
he would have went another way but he
didn't have that opportunity he had to
establish
what made my dreams possible he had to
establish the structure and so forth so
yeah i think that's that's definitely
something that kind of fits into what
how would how would happen like the jim
carrey documentary
where he talked about his dad yeah same
thing he wanted to provide for his
family he really cared for them
yeah but then to see his dad lose his
job in his like early 50s
yeah and he really had wanted to be a
musician i guess
right and how and that really stayed
with him yeah that's
it's it's something you'll never forget
if it happens to you in a way that where
your parents can
show vulnerability when you're younger
it's it's a tough thing because kids
usually
see their parents as just strength it's
just strength and then you
kind of lose that fantasy later on but i
actually saw that happen
and i think for me my dad is a truck
driver
for a company but he also did real
estate and
when the real estate market went put
i mean he literally lost more than half
his income within
like it was immediate it was immediate
for for most people
and the prudence that my dad had he
saved so much money
we always live way below our means so it
didn't affect him where he lost the
house or anything
but i saw something of this was the plan
the plan doesn't work
that's what i saw in his eyes so the
plan might not work even the safe one
why not
go against the safe and just try it like
especially when you're younger it's like
go for it why not so yeah do you think
that's where your courage to be an
artist
comes from that's a good question um i
think
courage is applied in all aspects
i think courage for me and confidence
comes from
work uh when you do things you see you
can do things
and then you get confidence and when you
get confidence you get more courage to
go to the next level like i'm not sure i
can do that
whenever i'd done something i wasn't
sure sure of and then i can go for it
and do more
um so playing sports young being the
only girl and a bunch of
brothers and cousins and all guys on my
block
and getting to play football with them
and then actually getting them like whoa
she did it she caught the ball when they
thought i wouldn't like little things
like that i think
all is a part of building a good
foundation of confidence
and then you get to school and then
you're like uh do i take the ap classes
let me go ahead and try you know
i might fail the first time but then you
do well and you're like wow you know
what next year i'm taking all ap
classes or whatever it is like little
little wins along the way
um i think help build our confidence
which ultimately builds the courage to
walk off
well you're not really sure what's next
yeah
at what age did you start writing
screenplays
um i started writing uh stage plays
first
i wrote my first i don't remember what
exact age it was but i helped write
at my church i helped write something i
was probably 10 or 12.
like in between that adolescent age i
helped like add some lines from a kid's
perspective
and then i wrote my own screenplay first
time in eighth grade so i was about 14
years old
um the one that i put on stage i did in
high school
um that was the first time i did all of
the stuff like stage manage direct
right all cast i did that um for my
senior project so i started beginning of
11th grade
the process and um doing that and for it
to be successful
like the whole school came out multiple
days to watch it and
then they were like hey have another one
then we can have one at night for the
parents you know it was like a really
good positive response to it and i was
like
oh it was like i did that like that
really
made me be fine with writing when i
didn't have any
paychecks because i knew i could do it i
just had to figure out my niche or
find a space that i could work in do you
remember the first screenplay you read
oh first screenplay i read i would say
first
uh stage play would be shakespeare i
would i was obsessed with shakespeare
when i was like
seventh grade i was like obsessed um and
then after that
screenplays um
try to remember the first i'll say the
early one i read um
um uh
then her i was trying to remember which
one i read ben hurt which is really odd
but the reason was i was in the library
i spent a lot of time at the library and
they had it
as the the um the like a book on ben hur
like the
backstory or something and then they had
like a little catalog thing you know
old library we can go and find other
things they had a script but it was on
the uh
the digital platform like we're not
digital we're digital now but whatever
that thing is
that we were looking at and they had
excerpts of ben hur it wasn't the full
thing but i got to read it and kind of
see
a movie i had seen a bunch of times my
mom always had us watch these movies ben
hur and such
um a movie i i saw see on the page and
it kind of connected some dots for me i
think and it wasn't
something that was conscious for me in
that moment but i think thinking back
like reading that made me understand
scripts a lot better
for sure yeah it's interesting so you
said you spent a lot of time at the
library usually i think of more
introverted people you seem more like an
extrovert you love sports
you're comfortable around sort of the
guys what was it about the library where
either you felt safe or what it whatever
it was um
i'm laughing because so i spent a lot of
time at the library because i couldn't
go many other places
like my mom like she it was certain
places we could just go and have freedom
the library was one of them so for a
person a kid that loved
freedom like yeah let me walk to the
store i'm ready you know that
you know i i knew i could go to library
and i didn't have to check in
it was just somewhere i could be um and
i love stories so if i'm at the library
i still feel like i'm an extrovert
because i'm i'm interacting with a whole
lot of people
they're in books but but i'm interacting
with a whole lot of people and then i
was like
friends with the librarian you know i
was that kid that would just
talk her off like in between reading and
it's like okay
thanks i have a lot of work to do so i
was definitely
talking to people as well but then also
interacting with characters in books and
um
i just loved the going through the
catalog and finding things like
something new
something random and i was really into
animals i still am but like
getting to read about different animals
and plants and things like that was
really cool to me and it's just
i just felt like there's a whole world
and i could just explore it and then go
talk to the librarian about it
yeah well you said movies were sort of
forbidden and maybe tv
well not forbidden very specific like it
was like
she had these vhs's we could watch and
then if a new movie has come out she had
to like research it she was very
on it like a very very um prudent parent
she wasn't very strict like where we had
a certain amount of time or anything
like that well tb yes we had like
like we couldn't go over an hour or
something like that but she was more so
the type of content we consumed she was
very very conscious of that she would
say watch what you
take in your eyes because it's going in
here like you know like very much
understanding that that was developing
something in us and then she encouraged
us
to just be out we spent a lot of time
outside in
a lot of scrapes and bruises and silly
silly
silly um breaking of bones because of it
but it was
it was i my generation grew up in front
of the tv
and i see a difference in me because of
that which sometimes is a disconnect but
then also it's like
oh i can hear what you're saying but i
also have a whole nother mindset because
i just didn't get a lot of things fed to
me i had to go out and search for it
so i think that her decisions were great
um
but yeah the library was a good place
for us to kind of
explore how did you learn to write
screenplays or stage plays i don't think
i ever learned it um i think
i i don't think i ever learned to write
screenplays or stage plays i think i
learned what was in a story that
connected with people
and then figured out how to put that
into lines
and i think that's really what it is
people go to school and they read these
books they're trying to just find out
what a story is and then how to relay it
but i think um consuming all types of
content
really is a thing that can teach you
that in such a way because it's like
okay i watch movies i go to the movies
multiple times a week it's my i don't
watch tv but i go to the movies all the
time
but i'm watching the audience too like
what was the moment where they kind of
leaned back and kind of settled in or
what was the moment that they reacted to
it well or kind of seemed a little
disconnecting on their phones or
whatever
um so yeah stories connect with people
and if you know how to connect with
people
outside of writing you can tell a story
and that's everybody so everyone has
some level of connection to people
so they can translate that to a paper
than your writer
and i have learned to do that by doing
it
doing it and hearing it and reading it
and seeing it um so
reading scripts helps yes but you got to
see the outcome of that scripture to
watch the movie
and you have to see the reaction that
the movie had on the people so go to the
movies
and you become a better writer i had an
english teacher
mr pomeroy in 10th grade back at
pennwood
in lansdowne pennsylvania and he said
people always say you become a better
writer by reading
and he said that's not true you become a
better writer by writing
and he would say to us every day into
his class he would say right
that would be his first word when we got
into the room and we were right
and there it was the most amazing class
it was an ap class and it was either you
got a a or an f
oh wow there was no grading of the
papers nothing it was either you did the
work you tried
you got an a you didn't do the work
you're not trying you'd have
so everyone in that class they wrote and
we grew
leaps and bounds without boundaries it
wasn't like oh am i getting a b
or it was just writing and that that was
very freeing
and i think that kind of gave me the
mindset that i have um
now where if i want to be a better
writer i need to write if i want to be a
better
whatever i need to do it so i applied
that thing that he told me i
think of him very finely very often
because he encouraged me in a way that
was invaluable just to write and that it
was good
and that i could impact people with it
that's really interesting so do you
think just the fact that he had such a
love for this
whereas maybe other parts of your life
movies had to be you know inspected you
saw the freedom
that he had with with story and it just
made you feel like you could be free
with writing
i think that the freedom my teacher gave
me in writing
could never be taken away the reason i
say that the next year
11th grade i had the most the teacher
it's like you have to do it this way
there's no way you wrote this
right now like she would have us through
these journal entries and she's like oh
no you didn't just write this and i'm
like
that's that's how my thoughts come out
and she's like okay it was just like a
very
negative space but i didn't lose what he
gave me i just like well let me see how
i can better interact with this
woman that wants me to do this and this
and this but i knew that i i already
achieved it and i had already
experienced it
so that experiential learning
i kept with me through that moment and
beyond so i still feel a sense of
freedom i think
for me sometimes i feel so much a
producer does
and we get so boggled down with tasks so
if i could just take a moment just to
write some things down
so totally disconnected from work i
always feel better and i think that's
something that he taught us like you can
free yourself
because you're getting your thoughts out
you're getting your thoughts organized
even
for anyone not just writers so anyone
that wants to kind of just bring
themselves back to center
writing is a great way to do it um so
that freedom yes he
he established it and it definitely
continued on and continues on um today
and i try to give that to other people
as well
so don't before i tell them what not to
do like just go and that's in anything
like um my wardrobe designer
my set designer like no just express go
like spend a day with it don't try to do
it the way that fits into this
just go for a day and then some
beautiful things could come out that
might have been kind of pushed down by
too much of a structure
in the bad moment you need the structure
because then i need to come and make
sure you're productive and all these
things but let them go first
and then you'll be surprised at how many
beautiful things come out
when you're writing a screenplay do you
start with an outline
i start with somewhat of an outline um i
need to know
where i am and then where i'm going or
where i just came from
so usually for me personally when i'm
starting to write it's not coming from a
from a starting place it's coming from a
scene i already had
so i write that scene out the most vivid
thing about what i think about this idea
i write that scene out without any it
doesn't have to fit anywhere i don't
know where this is but i just see
these characters doing this at some
point so i start there kind of kind of
get my groove going and start
to like yeah i really feel this moment
i've seen this moment i'm very a very
visual writer and a very
when ideas come to me they come to me
almost as like a movie um so i'm able to
write that down
and then now i go to an outline because
i don't i don't even know where this is
so i know i'm here but i don't know
where this is in the story or anything
like that um so i just start
with okay where's it ending where are we
going and then go from there so i kind
of
in a very non-linear way bounce about
the outline and then in the end which to
outline could take two months
i mean in the end i see it and i'm like
okay now this is some type of map
with the understanding that we can
deviate from it
how many scripts would you say you've
written even if you haven't shown them
to anyone ooh good question i have
written from start to finish on my own
five
um in a collaborative effort i i would
have to stay here and count
for a moment for a moment because i've
written on so many things and
helped writers do so many things so um
i'm not really sure how many that is
it's more than ten
um but for start to finish um is five
um on my own and then i have two three
maybe about four unfinished ones three
or four unfinished yeah
what are the pros and cons of writing on
your own and then writing
with either another person or a group of
people yeah um
pros and cons of writing on your own
versus a group i think changes for
everyone but for me
i'm a producer too so writing in a group
is wonderful
because if i can bounce ideas off of
someone not just in a way of like hey
i'm thinking of this and then go write
it hey i'm thinking of this that can
affect what they're writing
and vice versa it's so much better
because my brain
because i've it's just what it is i'm a
producer it will always go to a place
that has nothing to do with the script
like it will always it'll always creep
in somewhere but bouncing ideas off of
someone kind of vibing it out
that keep is that that keeps that at bay
enough where i cannot think about a
budget for a moment or i cannot think
about
this is too many locations you know
whatever it is i can silence that
productivity part of me and just like
feel free to write if i have someone in
the room
or if i have someone i can bounce off of
and for me and i know that can be
achieved on your own
but for me so far it's been the best
when i get to writing a group
do you have a clear vision of the ending
when you start a script
or does it come to you as the story
progresses um i have an ending for
not actually what happens but how i want
someone to feel so if i want an audience
to leave this feeling
happy and like wow that was just
that just uplifted my day i'm going to
keep that in mind the whole time but i
might not have the scene that that goes
with or
how exactly we get there because these
characters we're dealing with in a
moment are
having an argument or whatever it is but
if i want them to feel happy i'm
always keeping that in mind so i have to
leave little pieces of that throughout
the film for us to get there
um so i would say yes i would know the
ending of the film in in the moot
in the movie of like the mood or the
feeling but not necessarily
how that happens yeah you mentioned
earlier uh watching the audience which i
think is really fascinating because so
many people are
in their own world these days with the
phone and they barely look up at the
screen sometimes
what what is that that do you when you
see someone that's so
entrenched in you can tell that it's
really affecting i mean
i've sat next to people who were just
sobbing in a film and i was like
i don't know should i say something to
them i feel bad for this person but i
know i'm gonna let them be you know
but seeing how cinema affects people how
does that affect you
seeing how it affects other people um
i'm very empathetic
i'm extremely empathetic like to like
almost i'm not can't say a
fault but it's so it affects me so i
have to put guards up for it
so um seeing an audience being affected
by art and film or any
any audience to anything even art like
in the art gallery
it affects me a lot so if i look over
and see someone like
crying i might cry so um it affects me
in a way that
i can almost by looking at them feel
what they're feeling
and then like i said i can go back to
the film and think well what about this
make them cry
and then bring the logic into it like
wow that made them cry
i have no idea that means it's a
personal thing like they might have a
personal situation that
mirrors it because it's like a little
thing wow they're crying pretty
aggressively
for just you know this pretty calm
moment or
they the the writers and the filmmakers
were able to put something in place to
where
we're building you to a place that you
don't know it and then it hits you from
the side and then you see a more
aggressive cry than what you expect um
so i kind of try to
then unpack that like what happened here
to get them to that place or
um it's a the moment that's actually
actually happening right there
and what cinematography did they use to
be able to free the person enough to not
feel like they were in
watching a movie because that's
necessary for someone to cry in a way or
laugh in a way that's kind of freeing um
they have to not feel like they're in a
movie so
how the camera moved um sometimes the
camera's moving too much and the
person's like okay
like they're trying to follow something
or they feel like i'm watching a movie
rather than i'm i feel engrossed so
maybe
the camera kind of pushed in a little
bit and you felt like you connected a
little bit more with the character and
you felt like
i understand them now i'm gonna cry
because they're sad or whatever it is
that
affects us in any emotional way it's
interesting too when people laugh
and sometimes there's only just one
person laughing at something and it's
it's very telling you know and so it's
interesting to see
why people laugh at something yeah
comedy is tough
getting reactions in comedy that are
enough
of a widespread to hit most of the
audience because everyone thinks of
comedy is different most people think of
pretty much the same things as sad
scary whatever but funny that's hard
we all have such different personalities
and comedy but yet comedy is tough so
watching audiences be impacted and
laughing their heads off is always one
of those moments for me like i
am totally going to have to watch this
movie again because i want to see what's
happening here like you know so
i think watching comedies with a group
of uh people
um that don't know they're being watched
is just
so much fun for me and it teaches it
teaches me a lot um and i started in
comedy i mean i have a psychological
thriller right now and i'm doing a lot
of drama but
um i started um writing like slapstick
type stuff
and making people laugh from theater um
so getting to watch that in a film
setting a movie theater
it feels like theater it's like they got
it like going back to
the the church plays yeah church plays
and community theater
i worked at a a theater called hedgerow
theater up in pennsylvania a little
weird
theater weird in a good way yeah and um
that was my first experience with
professional audiences
and these you know intellectuals that
would come to see the theater
and um getting them to kind of loosen up
that that moment was something that i
looked for it's like we knew what we
were doing was right because
it's that moment where everyone came to
be seen or who's here and then all of a
sudden they're like
leaning in their chair or they're you
know they're having a good time or
or they're just like leaning forward or
whatever it is that
that's the moment that's when you have
an audience and seeing it in theater
makes it easier to understand and film
because there's no audience there but
it's okay because i kind of get an
audience
it's like this moment needs to happen
like this
or we need to bring this element into it
before we get there because we've
already
seen it so many times in a very
one-on-one or
uh interactive experience with theater
well you had something happen i believe
that's a writer's worst nightmare and
that is a script of yours was
stolen yeah i had a script stolen um
it was i have two scenarios that you can
say the word stolen but the one that
really
i think affected me deeply was i trusted
people
that wanted me to write and i was 19.
this was my first like higher for
um film like a film script that i'm
being hired to write
and i worked with people that i really
trusted
and they didn't do the wrong thing but
they didn't protect me to make sure the
wrong thing didn't happen or even
ask me questions to make sure i was
thinking of it and
the film they told me originally they
were like well this is not really where
we want to go
we'll circle back you know maybe a year
from now because we're going to go with
another idea and i was like okay no
problem
i enjoyed the experience i got to write
a films group start to finish and
just kind of waited and then i saw the
film um
it was uh maybe about two or three years
later and it was a little different but
it was
it was like that okay i wrote that line
you know one of those moments so
i think it was a horrible experience but
i can't say i'm glad it happened
but a lot of goodness came out of it it
caused me to be so much more prudent and
so much more watchful and wise
which is great for personal use but then
also
being someone on the other end now
hiring writers and so forth and even
something i'm working on right now in
pre-production
it's like i want to educate every young
writer
because it's something that no one's
going to i can't say no one but
there aren't many people that are not
going to want to use you for your gift
and that's a good thing but you got to
make sure they're using you in a way
that you're comfortable being used
so it's like it's fine your gifts are
here to be used and shown so don't feel
like
oh they're using me that's fine but just
put limits and boundaries on that
and that comes in with legal so most of
these young writers
most of them unless they got into a
place where they kind of shot up to the
top where they can have an agent and a
lawyer and this and that and somebody
watching out for them
they have no clue what paperwork needs
to be put in place and how
that paperwork needs to be worded to
where they're protected and because of
what i went through
i researched that and i didn't just
research it like now i know but i also
always bounce off a lawyer it's
even when i'm giving advice i'm like hey
this guy's dealing with this is this
does this claws mean this because that's
what i'm thinking um so just being very
very watchful of it and also i'm like
super protective of writers like it's
like
like it's like a mama bear thing that
comes out and um
a project i'm working on right now the
provider just like called me
just a couple days ago like i just
wanted to thank you like
you have been there for me every step of
the way you weren't even on the project
really yet because this is like
way before pre-production this was just
like conversations
and he was like i just felt so safe and
i couldn't have had a better uh
compliment than that the writer that was
around me felt safe because i
experienced the other way around
so i want to make sure that anyone in my
presence writers produce whatever it is
they feel safe and they feel that they
can trust like i did
but then also get the outcome that their
trust actually mattered and it was the
right person to trust
and i never want to like hurt that in
someone that's like something that i'm
very
mindful of and i don't think there's
there's an opportunity for us to make
bad decisions
like every person has that saying like
maybe greed or whatever the thing is
that
you see great people fall when you have
already experienced what great people do
to when they like what they can do in
power but you've been on the other end
of that
when you get some power you're gonna be
more mindful of how you treat people so
i can say that that
experience of having a strip a script
stolen makes me a better leader it makes
me a better producer makes me a better
writer
makes me a better person because i know
these people weren't bad people but they
saw an opportunity they're like well we
don't have to really
pay her anymore we don't have to really
bring her in she's not owed any points
let's just go
don't even tell her like that can happen
when you have greed so i
i don't look at them um i don't think of
them as horrible people i think of them
as
people that succumbed to to greed or um
because they could you know we all want
a sense of power and they use it the
wrong way
so it helps me use it in the right way
more often
and with more intention what's
what are some tips aside from having
legal look over
a contract or even emails
what what are some signs like a red flag
that a young writer should be
aware of i think signs of
red flags for young writers or any
writer is people
asking you for things that you one don't
understand or two
you didn't agree with already so it's
like
usually how it happens they kind of
sneak it in there it's like okay we have
an agreement and then it's like hey can
you also do such and such
and young writers especially they're
like i can't wait to do these things so
they just do it
don't do it be okay or even start
writing it start working on it but don't
tell them don't say okay
don't say oh absolutely just say oh sure
just have whoever called me so we can
just change it change the contract you
can do it in such a way that doesn't
seem like you're checking them just make
it seem like you're just
being helpful like oh i'll take care of
it i can talk to whoever let me know or
do i need to sign something else
ask an interesting question like that
and i tell you those people will adjust
their movements
just say oh great sure do i need to sign
something different and they say no
that will be the next red flag that it's
not only that they maybe
were negligent they were probably trying
to take advantage of you because you do
have to sign something there needs to be
an adjustment
and if they're not willing to do that
you don't need to be in the situation or
stay in a situation because we know we
got to be in
places sometime where okay be amongst
the snakes but
like the bible says be a dove like we
don't need to act like the snakes but we
need to know how the snakes move
be there and just keep very watch and
care on what you are doing and
presenting to them
so they're like hey where's that such
and such oh yeah i have it pretty much
ready i just need whatever paper i need
to sign
so bring it up later you want to fight
them you don't have to argue with them
you don't have to i i see another thing
and young writers are like
i read that such and such or my friend
said such and such and it's like
now you're just going to come off as a
jerk and that person might have been
innocent in this situation
so just come from an inquisitive place
and then
record that response i'm not saying
record every scenario or like have a
record like a phone recorder or whatever
but
after they responded write it down so
you can then think about it later and
then talk it over with a friend
um of course it's great to talk over
someone in the industry but even just
hearing yourself out loud talk to
someone
helps you kind of understand where
someone's moving so write it down
exactly what they said
send a text to yourself i do notes all
day off phone calls even when i'm
sitting on a call i'm writing down
certain
moments in the call just to kind of okay
what just happened here um so i think
just being mindful of like
requests and then seeing just seeing not
responding but seeing how they respond
to you pushing back on their requests in
any capacity and that will be a telltale
sign that this probably
is going to be a situation where people
are not going to protect you
so you can stay in it but just be ready
to protect yourself or bring someone
else in to protect you
i like that let's take the scenario of
where the person tries to turn it around
on you
and make it almost seem like you're the
one that's
the problem so let's suppose they say
well i only operate with a handshake and
i go on good faith like that
and i would hope you would trust me well
now that makes you feel like oh wow now
i look like i'm
mistrustful so you would almost want to
prove to them
okay oh that's fine yeah we'll do that
how do you when they try to turn it
around
as happen to a lot of people and make it
seem like it doesn't need to be
changed or initialed or noted i think
first
um first understand that your
trust has to be rooted in truth so trust
is built
you don't owe anyone it like just have
that stance i don't owe
trust to anyone they have to build it
and i have to build it for them
they don't have to trust me to go right
and do my job don't act like hey i'm a
writer i've done such and such either
you have the common humility but trust
has to be earned
now you don't have to tell them that but
have that stance so so let's say someone
says something like that where it's
well i operate on a handshake and i hope
you would trust me
absolutely i hope so too so i'm going to
start writing on this and just expect
that whenever you're ready you're going
to give me a piece of paper
or you're going to put this in writing
and then i can deliver it it's just for
me
man it's so many people out here that
you can't trust right like kind of
connect with them
right and then they're like what what
crazy person wouldn't be like
no trust everyone give them truth that's
why if your trust is rooted in truth and
you stay in a place of truth
you won't come off as combative or
difficult just stay in a place of truth
there's so many people out here right
yeah i get it yeah so for me i'm going
to start moving
sure but i just can't deliver anything
until that piece of paper only because
i've seen so many crazy things happen
and i don't think that would be you like
you know you have to put those things in
there to alleviate
you know something that could end up
being conflict but still
trust has to be earned so let them earn
it and also have that same stance on you
if you're not making deadlines if you're
you know not giving them proofs of
things and showing them the type of
examples that they want or providing
them with enough people that they can
call and say yeah they're great
whatever the case may be don't be
offended when they're not trusting you
either so you have to
understand trust you're not owed it and
you don't owe it to anyone but still
operate in a space of
by building it or for building it i'm
going to
just kind of confront them with truth
not in confrontation in a negative way
so i would say that's the way to deal
with it just kind of respond very
graciously but also then bring them a
truth that they can't disagree with
which is there's a lot of crazy things
happening here right and then go from
there
something that keeps coming up in our
interview today is like people skills
and just working with people and it
sounds like you've really
worked on yourself you've worked on
reading i know you've said that in prior
interviews that some
books on leadership are more important
than actually
film books and i find that very
interesting because most people
would do the opposite yeah i think um
we're in a business
with people this is a team sport i'll
say with football like football is a
team sport even with tom brady he needs
these receivers he needs
a college spread offense he needs
whatever he needs to make this happen so
with film you are dealing with people i
don't care if you're the most
brilliant savant in the world at some
point you're going to have to deal with
people
so for that reason anyone in the in the
industry especially producers especially
um writers because you have to be able
to convey your thoughts and ideas
and not just you know hold it in here
and only do it on paper you have to
actually talk some time
just working on your people's skills in
a way that is uh
practical reading um going to
conferences
hearing things listening to audios
things like that um
i read uh leadership books for far more
than i read entertainment books or film
books or screen writing books
and the reason is i can of course become
a better writer or a better producer
or better filmmaker by learning the x's
and o's just like in film i'm sorry just
like in football
but how am i going to get this team to
operate right or how am i going to get
myself to operate within that team
correctly that's a people skill so if
you build that the rest of it can be
worked on
it can be be forged in practice but you
come into a situation you have not
practiced and you have not built that
people skill you're going to disqualify
yourself before you even get to show
your art and get to show how brilliant
you are and all the stories inside of
you
so many people i don't i don't think
failure usually comes from
people that have don't have the ability
but it usually comes because they didn't
have the
emotional iq to handle the pressure
the conflict the anything that can
impede success is usually a personal
issue it's not because you didn't know
not knowing something i mean we're in an
informational age you can google
anything
so with all this information at our
fingertips and people are still dropping
off like
in such a bad way they cheat on their
wife it's a horrible
like it's like expo if you're on every
channel you've done such and such or
you treated your employees bad and
they're all blogging about it the new
york post now has an op-ed from your
ceo or whatever that just quit whatever
happens that's not because they didn't
have the ability
in their business in their enterprise so
it's they're filing because of
a personal problem so if you work on
yourself you can be better in any
industry especially ours because it
truly is
a team effort and as creatives we
we want to flow and have the freedom to
create but it's like to have freedom
if you don't have the money because
money also operates same but to our
freedom
the only way is for someone to open a
door for you and not close those doors
in your face
that's how we get freedom that's why
christopher nolan can make
whatever he wants because he was able to
put himself in a place not just to be
brilliant because there's so many
brilliant people there christopher
nolan's age
that had the same schooling but they're
not christopher nolan
he did something to where teams and
people
at opportune times open doors for him or
he could freely create
and i don't think that only comes with
brilliance because i know so many
brilliant people that are like
not doing anything with their life or
even
stuck in some little office somewhere
wishing that they could
create so yeah for the doors to open you
either need a boatload of money for
mommy and daddy or you need to have
people skills
in some capacity so working on that is
very important
was there an example that you saw of
someone and you don't really have to
name their name but
where you just saw how they handled
something and it was so brilliant how
they defused
the situations we know film sets it's a
long day
or even if it's just an email people
they get sensitive
and they get mad and maybe they take
things the wrong way
or they're not i know we talked about
people not knowing the word no
or they can't handle the word no you
know which it's interesting when you say
that to someone and you see how they
react
but did you ever see someone where they
just they handled it brilliantly and you
were like wow i want to be like that
yeah um for me the first example was a
negative one
on film sets watching producers
specifically
be horrible to people and they led and
they motivated through fear
and paychecks that's the motivation i'm
paying you
work or you're scared of me work or
you're intimidated or where whatever it
is
so it's like the producer's coming to
set everybody's all of a sudden like
okay or the ad is just like cursing you
out instead of just yelling
hey i need you guys to do x y z for this
day to go forward whatever it is
so i saw the negative part of it but as
a child i saw the positive and then i
also
had the opportunity and the blessing to
know chad morton
my executive producer on the last film i
did he is
the money guy but yet he is the nicest
person
and also we had a situation in another
project where
someone cheated us like they were
submitting work um artwork
that was stolen um it was totally not
they were submitting these things that
were not theirs and we found out about
it
and the way he handled it was so amazing
to me i was ready to rip this girl's
head off like
how could she she could have ruined
everything because i was like if these
got out we could have been sued and all
this crazy stuff
and he had a conversation with her and i
was i was with him
and um she fought him vehemently and
said negative things to him and just was
horrible and he said i'm sorry you feel
that way
the only thing i'm here for is to tell
you you won't be working with us anymore
and i hope you don't do this with anyone
else
i wish you all the best and he didn't
even respond to the negativity and we
went about our business and i was like
that's it you're not gonna
rip a new one like you're not gonna sue
her and it was like
he said something to me i can't remember
the exact words but he didn't want to
let that negativity go any further than
what it already did
we experienced something that was very
real we we had to get in front of it and
we had to deal with it we dealt with it
we got rid of her we got a router for
artwork we wasted money she wasn't
giving that money back we had already
paid her
and everything but if he continued to
dwell on it
and complain about it and continue to
try and get money from her that he
he wasn't getting this money then now
we're still in a negative space
two three weeks from now a month from
now when we could have just one about
our business and solve more problems
found more artwork or whatever it was
so i think that for something that i
learned from chad just kind of like
let things be a little bit more easy and
rub off like roll off your shoulders
um in a place of grace and in a place of
like selfishness like i don't want to
take this negativity with me today
i hear what you're doing i'm not even
going to respond to a negative i'm going
to correct the problem
just logically and then walk away and
then on the flip side of that
watching film producers 80s etc
rule in a fearful or just i'm paying you
do your work type way
i'd already as a child for my pastor my
dad different people
in my life saw leadership without that
without the negativity servant
leadership so that's how i
my leadership it fits more into the
servant leadership mindset
where i'll just give you a quick little
baby story my pastor like
he would be the guy this is the pastor
right like he's sweeping when we came
into
the church he's sweeping up things and
um this other gentleman walked up i was
like
pastor no no no let me do that please
don't ever do that so he took it from
him and he walked away and i was a
little inquisitive girl that just saw
this moment i was like
why did you want to sweep and he's like
it's not that it's just
it had to be done and it wasn't even a
big deal to him he's like it had to be
done
i had some time and it was like oh and i
think just being a kid seeing that
or like my dad who was my coach in
soccer like he just always led with not
put downs he led with positivity and
then also he led with
the idea that let me make you better
like let me make you better
so i'm gonna be really hard on you but
i'm coming because i care about you i'm
going to make you better so when you go
to the next level you're better
like let me do that for you and he would
say that to the kids like
hey i'm only talking to you because
you're messing up but i can help you
because i've already done it
so that's that the stance i have with
anyone that works with me
for me in any with like any capacity i
want to make everybody in the room
better
and vice versa they're going to make me
better too they're going to grow me
especially they have a bad attitude
you're going to work so hard to get to
that person in a way that kind of
diffuses that
you're going to be better now i can on
the next one i mean attitudes don't mean
anything to me someone that has a
negative kind of like continence about
them counting it excuse me
i'm like oh this is easy i'm ready for
that like i've experienced like the most
like dramatic and negative people on
sets and it's like oh we're fine so
they it's don't panic i saw such
negative um motivations on set uh
negative um you know put down
or stay in your place or whatever and i
saw the outcome of that which was a
great movie
but also the people were not happy so it
could have been even greater
and i really believe that when you were
working with the team if you make
everyone feel
comfortable but also
high expectation like you're cared for
but you have a high expectation i found
that that's the best
fit for me to motivate so yeah rachel
expects
this from you and you feel like you only
could do this but i see that in you i'm
not just gonna be like
do this i'm gonna say let me help you
get there and i learned that from my
father it's like let me help you get
better let me help you
but i'm not gonna take oh i can't do it
or this is what i have to offer
no i'm not taking that but i care so
much about you i'm gonna stay up tonight
and talk to you on the phone
and we're going to go through all that
you just worked on yesterday and i'm not
going to sleep
and i'm fine with that because i want to
help you get better so um
that idea i think was fashioned in front
of me as a child
and i apply it but the real issue is
in film that's the usual case is the
adverse and
we've learned though like me going on to
set if i hadn't had any other idea that
it could actually work in a big way
without that then i'm thinking oh when i
get there i have to leave with the iron
fist or they won't do their jobs
now i do believe that high expectations
are so necessary for people to grow i do
but iron fist isn't because
you'll never be able to motivate someone
past self-motivation
because you're only trying to match what
is inside of them so whatever's inside
of them can go further than you can push
them to
if you can unlock it instead of pounding
it so it's like
unlock that person and they'll work
harder and i learned that actually
from my hands in producing events not
film
and i and that's another thing for
producers it's great that you produce
film but have you had
any form of leadership in your life
other than film and i think for me that
that
that gave me a balance so the leadership
was in sports being the captain on the
team or something
but also producing events because okay
i'm an event like the u.s open or
whatever
and these people the the client is
saying
these people are lazy they're not
smiling they're not this they're not
that
and then finding out instead of just
firing a person are they being utilized
in a place that fits their personality
that person's not a greeter that person
is an
extrovert and you're telling them you're
saying they have a bad attitude because
you sat them at an information desk and
they're the person that should be
working
over there helping out with tech or
whatever it is so finding places so no
knowing that part of it it's not the
same in film you can't say oh let's try
you unit production manager today
but you can realize that that person
wants to do this
if you're on a film set you want to do
it in some capacity maybe they want to
be a director
and they're just a pa but they want to
be here so why
we have an opportunity to do the best
kind of leadership because in other
corporations you got to deal with
i do not want to be here i don't care
about coca-cola or whatever the thing is
i care but everyone in film they care
about film they like movies
so use that what is it about you and
this is what i do when i first bring
someone onto my team
what's your dreams in this business what
are your goals and even just hearing
that kind of gives you an idea so when
you see that person underperforming and
something that they want
for life you have to know it's not
because they're lazy
it's because their motivations are off
or they don't feel empowered enough or
they're not able to verbalize something
that's bothering them
so don't panic when you see a negative
thing and start cursing everybody out or
thinking that's the only way to handle
it
in a war type mentality like day of you
have to handle it
quickly but then you can always circle
back because even if i have to be like
guys this is happening move that's
different than guys
move something's happening move and i
haven't connected with you the day
before
i didn't connect with you after the film
you have to establish care first
to then give advice power push
motivation because if i haven't showed
them that they're not going to respond
to me
with anything but fear like we talked
about motivating and fear
or oh i got to get paid so let me just
go ahead so i'm limiting
their input and their initiative in a
situation that i needed i need them to
be
excited to be here i need them to want
to do it so why not help them do it
as leaders we sometimes act like oh
these people are lazy oh they're
negative well
change it what about the culture of your
set or what about the culture of
how you hire them tells them that you
don't care so that
yeah they're bringing that to the set i
don't care they do care
they're in film they want to be in film
so they care
so i had that understanding don't panic
when you see a negative response and
take ownership in that be a servant
leader take ownership that well maybe
there's something i can do on my end
and if there isn't because sometimes
it's totally the person i'm going to
confront it in a way that lets them know
it's not just the action that's going to
cause us a problem you're hurting the
team
you're hurting yourself and guess what
next time i might not be able to bring
you on
and if i don't bring you on and i care
about you what's going to happen for the
guy that doesn't
they're not even going to be bothered
with you so let me help you what's the
problem let me help you through it
and then we can we can achieve something
better rather than just like oh
these idiots or whatever the place you
could come from that i see happen on
sets
all the time
what makes a great story what makes a
great story
um i think ultimately if it
evokes an emotional response whatever
that emotion is whether it be elation
sadness fear if it evokes an emotion
it's a great story
how that happens is so many things and
so many things but it has to evoke
something
because it's not the people leave
feeling like okay
that was smart like you know like it
could be brilliant but did they feel
anything from it so i think if it evokes
an emotion um through the story not just
a random
you know through the story evoking
emotion it's a good story
have you watched a film where you could
tell other people weren't into it but
you were
or vice versa it was one that was
recommended the critics all loved it
and you're like yeah i just it didn't
get to me right here yeah it normally
happens the other way around where i'm
like this was awesome and people were
like
i didn't get anything from it i'm like
what um but yeah sometimes where
you hear all these things about a movie
people love it and i'm like
this is all right usually it's something
that's very niche so in this day and age
where
things can go viral like that like it's
just boom everyone loves it
but it's usually a core group of people
loved it and they spread it because they
were so excited about it because it
felt it fit a certain niche that they're
in and then other people will follow
because people are
cheap the masses follow the masses and
they're like oh it's great and then it's
great it's great it's great it's great
and it gets to be this huge thing and
then someone coming into it they're like
um it's okay but it's it wasn't their
niche
and most of the people are watching it
say it's great it's probably not their
niche they're just cut they're
grabbing onto the truth that someone
else told them and they're going into it
with expectations
and bringing their own like someone
else's excitement into the into the room
so i found that usually when a story
doesn't necessarily connect with me or
wow me and some people are really
excited
it's a personal thing like maybe um i
know this one movie i watched and
uh i cried on it like i don't cry a lot
of movies
but i cried and i was like reading
reviews and they're like it was
disconnected
it didn't talk to the audience i you
know it was just bashing
the connection part which i'm like i
cried but i realized
i had a personal thing that connected
with that movie so for me
it was a great movie so that's all we
need to do as writers producers
filmmakers we only need to connect
with the audience and we need to connect
in a while a wide enough space
for people to love it and then we have a
story we have a movie
what takes you out of a film what ruins
a story for you
um for me it's tough when i feel like a
lack of authenticity in a in a project
or
or film or script um that can take me
out of it
i can just it's kind of just okay
because they they maybe said something
the actor says something
um the character is speaking and i know
i just met the character for like
a whole 30 minutes that doesn't fit what
they're doing that doesn't fit what
they're saying so i felt like they tried
to
push a narrative or push something
because it felt right for
or fun for the project but it's like but
you just introduced me to the character
to be something different
and if a character steps out of
themselves and acts in a way that's
completely off the way they should act
or the way they uh
um are prone to act there should be
something that tells me that there's an
opportunity for that to happen so a man
that is so loving and kind then all of a
sudden
is mean to his wife i'm like oh my gosh
what's happening rather than like
okay so i have to stay connected by
proof
and truth so we stay authentic in
stories we if we come from a place of
truth
and for a writer that's knowing the i
mean the the characters that you're
writing and knowing what they would say
for a producer it's keeping an eye on
the full picture
watching it and making sure everything
fits into that from what the character
is wearing all these things
you can't hire a wardrobe designer that
doesn't think about okay this guy is a
blue collar guy
we need a lot more wear and tear on his
clothes that could take me out the
moment
it's like okay that guy's jacket is very
fresh
i'm out and i don't blame the the just
the wardrobe designer on that i blame
the producer
because if you see these things you're
keeping an eye on everything and uh the
upm and all these people like you're
tracking people you should know that
something is off here and it should be
adjusted and should be conversations
about the director should be talking to
your creative
team on a regular basis and they do they
all do to where
you understand that everything i'm
telling you about the story i know the
director
you're going to take the story and then
apply it to your niche
so the production design it shouldn't be
bright and colorful if we're about to go
into a dark space like let's bring it
down
let's get some real material in there
let's not have a lot of you know
brand new type materials let's get some
wood in there let's get some
some metal in the scene or whatever it
is like i want everyone to have that
same vision and then apply it
so producer make sure your director has
a vision and make sure they know how to
convey it if they're not conveyed step
in and make sure you
you're intervening and making sure that
he's able to do it or she's able to do
that
and then on the writer's side the same
thing do you know your characters you're
pitching a story to me you want me to
get financed
tell me about the characters oh well in
the script they do know not what they do
in the script
tell me about them like tell me about
their lives so then i'm when i'm reading
the script
red flag nope you just told me that that
guy is like
really uh narcissistic you told me that
when i met you and now i'm reading
this care moment why is he having a care
moment you didn't prove it well it's
care because this is the moment where he
changes
okay prove it show me so the audience
doesn't feel good disconnected so i
think would
easily you can pull an audience out by
not remaining authentic in any capacity
writing production design wardrobe hair
makeup anything it all needs to be
with the director's vision in mind and
that director should have a
very strong vision that can be applied
throughout and that's the producer's job
to make sure it happens
what's the idea behind what death leaves
behind
the idea it's based on a true story
inspired by a true story and chad morin
my executive producer
he came up with the idea because his
cousin had
a kidney transplant after that kidney
transplant he started to have nightmares
immediately
actually he had his first one in the
hospital directly after the
transplant and those nightmares were
graphic and they were horrific
um there's a man and a woman beating on
each other and it was like
very much not something that connects
with his life usually a dream in
something that's somewhat connected to
something that we've experienced and
it's just
so far from him he's like this
happy-go-lucky guy and he kept having
these dreams every night
so having those dreams he called his
cousin chad and
started telling him hey can you stay up
with me can we just talk and he's like
okay i'll talk
i know you just had surgery but then it
just became ridiculous and chad kind of
probed and
here we are we found out about these
streams chad told me about it he had an
idea to make it into a movie
i was like it sounds awesome and he
wrote the first script that we um
inspired everything that we did from
there you started working on the script
once it had already been developed or
you were writing it fresh
um that's a good question so chad wrote
the
first draft um with nico giampertro
and it was a really good more campy
horror type film and when this was
i was already on it i was the producer
from the from day one even before chad
wrote it but
um when they first submitted the first
script um
we knew we needed to make some
adjustments to get us to where we were
and nico brought a lot of adjustments
into chad's idea because
chad was so close to the subject matter
so he had a lot of reality to it and
also he had a
little bit of a boundary because it's
your cousin like how can you write your
cousin doing a bad thing or
reacting negatively it's kind of like we
go back to that being authentic like
it wasn't as it authentic as someone
dealing with something so drastic so we
had to go deeper
and so from where chad um brought it and
nico elevated it
scott and i the director was my
co-writer like we were in the trenches
together and we wrote
what you now see in the film and a lot
of chad's original
words are still in their original lines
just applied differently
and we even while writing together
scott and i would call chad up and say
hey because he's a father of five boys
oh i have one son this guy has no kids
so i'm like
this is an older situation he has some
older kids hey
how would you say this what would you do
and he just write and send it to us so
it was a very collaborative effort and
it kind of was birthed in a very organic
way
um i enjoyed that process that organic
birthing of this thing no one really had
like a
you're this writer or that it just kind
of worked out and then another thing we
uh realized along the way especially
scott and i
i spoke from certain characters uh in a
way that
was better than him and he definitely
spoke from a certain character the main
character especially
far better than i could so it was like
one of those things where i could write
a whole scene
and he like great and then he rewrite
all of his lines
and it really was like shortening them
like less because he
is his perspective and i adapted it like
man that's awesome
was that this character was dealing with
some so much
internal turmoil he wouldn't be saying
that much
even in that moment take it back even
more so we all had the idea of
uh jake the character the main character
and what definitely behind should speak
less but i didn't i didn't even speak
less enough
to get what we wanted so he would take
away take away adjust
and same for me like certain characters
of his it was like oh she'd go a little
deeper and it wasn't always like a
man-woman thing
it was like um a more um
vulnerable less vulnerable thing so the
men
in a very vulnerable space would be
maybe something i'm tweaking
or the woman when she's like bringing it
she's like
going in on her husband i'm writing it
because i'm married
but then scott was like what if she says
this i was like oh that's ugly you know
so it was a very organic space um we
wrote it together
of all of us but it also was a very um
we all brought our own self to it
um in a very interesting way how long
did that rewrite process
take oh that's a hard one we were
writing um
we were writing the script even in
production
we had a script totally done but we
would literally maybe a week before
where
we're going to film the scene need to
adjust it because the beauty of what an
actor brought
last week and i say that because we had
veteran actors in our film and we this
was our first feature
like our very first one doing it at this
level and
how can we then tell that actor that was
too much emotion
we just had to make sure we proved it
and we had to make sure we built
something in that would adjust it or
whatever
so yeah we wrote the the draft that we
came up with was like
pretty quick i would say less than a
month but
the tweaking and the changing
i mean it happened up all the way
through production to be honest like it
was just it was an
ongoing process a night before one scene
i actually was writing
and going back and forth with the actor
about it that's how free it was because
he's like well
um actually that one was actually shower
barton shower bar and i was like hey
and she's married too i was like this is
where it is and she's like
you know what i was thinking and you
know we're pulling from our own little
moments with our husbands and then
expanding upon it and she said that i
was like you're right
change it before we even had sex you
know they can improv in things but this
is not an improv thing this is like
what's your motivation you're coming
from a different angle we're changing
angles which will change lines
so she had totally she was amazing she
would learn those lines like that
and the next day she's doing it and that
happened with quite a few of them and
then vincent young
he would change the script on his own
like at set
and it was better than what we wrote so
now that's how we're filming it
now of course you now got to make sure
he got all the elements but just the way
he delivered it
was just so much better because he just
really settled into his character andrew
in such a way that
was just it was just so organic he just
kind of became him so he would say
things i'm like i didn't write that
like that's good so scott our director
he just i mean he
was so secure in his vision where he let
everyone feel free
to bring themselves into it in a way
that was just free-flowing to where
everyone can
feel free to move within this structure
of where we're going
so i can commend scott for that because
i think a lot of times
directors are any creative of course
we're so passionate about our vision
but we can be so passionate about our
vision where we don't see that a vision
is not a square
cube it's a fluid thing it moves it
shapes our visions change every day
so if you're creative you know that you
can be inspired and
shift so of course you can be inspired
and shift from people too
so allow the actors of course have us a
culture where on set there is a boss
scott is the boss here we have a
director if he says this that's what
we're going with
but before that what are you missing on
set when you shut everybody down
before you were able to let them have
the experience of like hey i was
thinking of this
or whatever so we were able to do that
with this film which i i really think
that
the actors appreciated it and we were
able to do it because we're so small too
because sometimes you have a studio
that's like ah this is what we approved
so we didn't have that
so when we're smaller yes it's harder
because you're like
counting pennies and you're moving this
to have that you're
taking away from that to pay this but
then you have freedom to
say yes a lot more without saying okay
give me one second and calling up
eight people to get to a yes or no
when we were talking about outlining
earlier and you said that you don't
necessarily
have an ending in mind but you know how
you want the audience to feel
which i thought was great so that that's
sort of your ending point
with what death leaves behind what did
you want the audience to feel
for me what definitely is behind was my
job was to capture what chad originally
felt when hearing these stories which
wasn't pleasant
you have someone calling you and you're
they're telling you the most
horrific things they've ever seen and
it's a dream okay
but you're having this dream every time
you go to sleep
so that feeling that's that chad had and
then told me about and then i had that
feeling
that's the feeling we needed to give the
audience i don't necessarily want to
make someone feel bad
but it's not going to feel like wow it's
gonna feel like oh my gosh or
oh okay like it's it's it's a feeling of
tense it's a feeling of unsure it's a
feeling of
care and empathy it's so much into that
it's layers of the feeling that you
leave with and so much so where
we were on our festival run we would
have q and a's that were supposed to be
10 minutes or 50 minutes they would be
45 minutes long and the
theater is kicking us out because people
just the empathy that we saw for these
characters was
amazing and i and it's not just like wow
we did it we wrote but it's like
this deals with a lot of real issues our
movie it's it's an entertaining
psychological thriller it's gonna make
you feel
you know suspense and have you guessing
in the mystery of it
trying to unveil and it has a hitchcock
ending but also there's real elements
there's
domestic violence in the dream there's
um
kidney and dialysis issues there's
transplant issues that are very real for
i mean america especially like we have
so many people waiting for transplants
and dying like it's like
these are morbid things that are real
but also we're entertaining
so i wanted them to feel entertained but
i also want them to feel
a sense of responsibility
and a sense of i care for that person on
screen
so if i interact with someone that's
going through any of these things i
might interact with them a little
different with a little more empathy
with a little bit more care with a
little bit more understanding so i
wanted them to feel that
and i think scott really directed in a
way
that brought us to that moment and we've
seen so many
like i said we were we won 17 awards so
in the festival run and now we're
starting our
theatrical run but the awards are nice
but it was like getting to interact with
people at film festivals is amazing it's
like
whoa i knew we did something but it's
like this person is telling me their
personal business
at a q a in front of people how does
that happen because
there feels like a safe space where we
we dealt with some really tough issues
in a way that was of course entertaining
but also
we dealt with it with a lot of care like
dialysis and
uh kidney transplants we we had real i
actually casted real nurses
on set to be the nurses just so we knew
we got it right
so it's like we have people like i've
never seen a film where i felt that they
really handled dialysis right and like
whoa that's because we brought a renal
nurse in to tell us how to do that
so we trusted our vision but we also
trusted the people that we brought in to
kind of
guide us to those moments of sensitive
subjects and aaron o'brien plays
the woman being abused in the dreams and
she just brought
just a strength and a vulnerability at
the same time that was
amazing amazing to see
on set and then to watch it on film um
and she handled that because she
actually dug in and like communicated
with people
that went through it domestic violence
it wasn't like a caricature like oh
you're hurting me it was like
strength and fight and grit but also she
didn't make
a decision in the film that would have
maybe brought her a sense of peace
because she's
she's abused so anyone that's we're
people we don't want to be hurt like
babies right away they feel
uncomfortable they cry we don't deal
with hurt and pain
we want to get away from it so someone's
staying in a place of hurt there's
something happening here
and it's usually control or whatever so
she was able to bring that without us
talking about it was not a domestic
violence film
but if someone's dealing with that in
the audience
they see it as truth because that's
exactly what that woman that man
whatever is dealing with
and they see it portrayed in a way
that's very authentic and i think that
that was just
a really good takeaway for us as
filmmakers yes we want to entertain
we want all these people to go see it we
want people to buy tickets we want
people to
download them tod but also it's like we
want them to like
feel something that is something that
they can take with them
and i think that that's what we achieved
if nothing else we achieved that would
what definitely is behind and i don't
know if the word underdog is the right
term but
it's the main character trying to
convince the medical community
that this is really happening because
they're sort of labeling him as he's
crazy or it says medication
side effects yeah so we deal with cell
memory i'm sorry
yes we do we deal with cell memory
theory in the film and the idea that
this guy is dealing with it and no one
really takes them serious they're like
you have a kidney you're more healthy be
happy and he's like
i'm not happy i'm having dreams i'm
scared i think something's wrong here
and you can apply that to something like
cell memory theory and it's very much
a moment of controversy and people don't
agree or they agree it's a scientific
theory
but just apply it to normal life we do
this to our friends and our family so
often where we don't take with their
own personal journey serious enough and
we have
suicides and all these crazy things that
happen but if someone knows that
i care about you and even though i don't
really vibe or
can relate to what you're going through
i'm going to open myself up and at least
believe you
and give validation because we all
search for that we need validation in
what we
experience so just to say i don't
believe you
right off the bat is so disconnecting so
for for jake in the movie
that was the problem no one believed him
and that
ultimately started him on the road of a
spiral
down to the ending so it's like
i think that that's a a telltale sign in
our lives when we see
a person dealing with something just
just to be a little bit more open to
something that's not necessarily your
your thing
and um take it more serious um we
actually had someone in the q a tell us
that like hey
watching this helped me understand my
brother better who was dealing with some
depression
which is not really something we deal
with in the movie but mental health
really is attached to it because even
though he has a very physical problem
the way he handles it is a mental
problem because just because you have a
physical problem doesn't mean
you know you see so many people they
break their legs or they lose their legs
and they're like champions but then you
see someone else that never got over it
and you know took too much medication
and eventually just kind of
lived their life out so it's a mental
problem it's not a physical problem
so jake had a very mental problem
started with a physical situation that
probably brought it up
it wasn't that the mental problem was
from physical but it would bring it up
in a way that would
cause this man that was very secure in
his life to feel vulnerable because then
he loses his health at a young age
he loses his family he loses his wife
these things
what man wouldn't react negative in that
moment so if you can see him react
negative and you've already established
that you're empathetic to jake
then when you see him act crazy or act
like paranoid and start doing crazy
things in the film
it's entertaining and you're like whoa
he's crazy he lost it but then also
when you see your family member kind of
act out and snap at thanksgiving dinner
you're not like they're crazy get them
out of here you're like wait what's
happening here
just kind of being a little bit more
open to that idea that
there's something happening deal with
that rather than shunning the person
what five things does the screenplay
have to have to make you interested in
being a producer for it five things a
screenplay has to have to make me feel
interested for one like i said emotional
response
like i need to know how i feel after i
read it if i feel like
what was i supposed to feel now you
gotta go back to your drawing board
um so yes uh you have to know the
feeling
the feeling needs to be there some
something some type of feeling at the
end of it
the other thing is a true identity in
what genre it is
and if not it's okay because i can i can
do that i can help with that
but if the person doesn't know what
genre they're in
it's not that you have to play by the
rules but you need to know the rules
before you break them
and they're telling me oh i just made
this awesome horror film and i'm like
this is hilarious
like i just watched it and horror and
comedy can
intertwine but it's like you're going to
break a rule here let me make sure this
is what you meant by this like
so it needs to have a really strong
identity in its genre
um another thing it needs to have is
somebody that's
either i can't say rooting for but
someone that
a mass audience like most people can
connect with
um we're in a time where you know people
are a little bit more open to different
things
so i think that's that's something that
we're kind of having to like
tested the thermometer on like where are
we as a culture like what is now
accepted or whatever but
you have a good idea just from living
life and watching the news like what
people accept
or scroll through social media you could
get an idea of how they connect with
things and
um uh how they they see things so if
if i have no one in that film that i see
myself in
there's a problem because i can see
myself in a lot of ways i'm very
versatile i don't think i'm like this
person that has to
only see this and only see that so if i
don't see something that i can connect
with
we're missing something so a connection
to a character doesn't have to be a main
character
but a connection to a character in a way
that brings a person in
where like okay that could be my buddy
yeah i would say that too or whatever
if it's so far off in like overly
avant-garde or artsy
i just need to be told then this is what
that's supposed to be
and then all right great you want to
make it here's a little teeny budget
and i'll help you get into some weird
festivals like you know they're like no
i want this to be on every you know
theater and i'm like well we can't work
together
because that's not going to work so yeah
as long as as long as it has um someone
that can
connect to and actually actually kind of
brought me to the other point
um the first thing i ask a person before
we i even read their script is
where do you see this going and that
kind of tells me and it's funny
someone's always like oh i never thought
of that and i'm like well
you know you have to know where you're
going to know how to do it you have to
know where you're going
to know where to move and where to focus
on and where to face so if they don't
know where this
if they wanted to go that's going to
make my job a little harder now i can
read it and be like oh
this can do this but at least let me
know where you see it and then when i'm
reading it i can kind of say
yeah you got it or you don't and are you
fine with not having that
you would have this outcome are you good
with that yeah you know what i am
great or no i'm not well you're gonna
have to go back to this rewrite it
have much less location so we get you a
bigger star because this thing is not
going to sell
you know like something like that so um
yes
a good i guess that would be direction a
good focus point of
uh where they wanted to go that helps me
and then i guess for number five
um it has to be
relevant to the immediate culture
that doesn't mean it needs to be
happening but just relevant for instance
i think
some movies that were so good that
didn't do well it was like if they just
waited a couple more years it would have
worked
because we were moving to that but this
guy has a very strong opinion on it this
director or this writer or whatever
so if he's going to come with this
opinion it's going to kind of disconnect
and people are not going to spread it or
finances are not going to get down with
it or um
you know the distributor won't readily
just
open the door they'll probably throw it
on netflix somewhere and bury it or
whatever
it's because they just it was such a
good project such a good story but it
just wasn't time for it yet
and i think for producers they have to
be very mindful of that
um it's not just keeping up with current
events it's kind of just talking to
people
and making sure that you're in a very
diverse group of people i think every
producer if you're only talking
to your buddies from school it's a
problem you need to talk to people from
different backgrounds
different financial backgrounds
different races different
ethnicity everything you need to expand
your horizons travel
when you go to even if you just travel a
state over go to like
don't go to applebee's i mean but like
eat applebee's when you're home but if
you're in another place go to like the
little mom and pop and just kind of sit
at a diner and talk to some people
because i'm thinking wow this is such a
great idea i go to montana these people
will never watch this
so it's okay if it's not but i gotta
keep that in mind so if i'm not i have
no idea what's going on i think like
even with the political culture right
now people like
i didn't know people thought like this
i'm like i did i toured all the country
doing merchandise events like i believe
me this is nothing new but it's like
that's necessary when you're the person
a producer
that is is in a position to choose what
stories are made
or choose which stories you're going to
push through or find financing for
choose the right ones for the time and
tell the person if it's not ready they
might fight you on it you might lose the
project and they might do it anyway and
then you'll see that they
you were right but if you communicate in
a way a person can get down with it and
then for writers
just know like when you're writing let
yourself run free but also be aware of
what's happening around you and that
doesn't mean your idea can't happen
you just might need to adjust it so it's
like the little you know like
sugar with the medicine type of thing
like a little bit of sugar
just add a little sugar in it so it's a
little bit more palatable for where
we're at
that way we can spread it to the world
and everyone can see your art but if
you're
staying in this space and you're
futuristic and you have this whole idea
where we're going
like okay let's now we gotta add more
budget make it futuristic then it can't
be now because we're not there yet or
whatever so
yeah being very mindful of what's
happening what the culture is and seeing
when i'm reading that script
can someone accept this as truth right
now and
you'd always be a couple no's and you
got to know who those notes are
but if it's multi yeses all right we can
now move forward
do you also go to movie theaters in
other in your travels
in towns where the industry is not
prevalent or it's not a big city
and this is like the main focus of the
town like there's nothing else to do
here
i do i go to a lot of movies that in a
town where
there is nothing else to do but movies
and i mean nothing like in the middle of
nowhere
and it's very interesting um their take
on things and i like
especially in those areas right after
the film those
people talk the most they will give you
the
ins and outs and i learned this by
seeing it but i also
learned it from somebody that we don't
like to talk about right now but harvey
weinstein
he established something where he would
put in a strip mall
a random in the middle of jersey where
nobody goes anywhere but the movies and
to
like the club like in the club is a pub
right like he put he would use that
theater as his litmus test
so he would put it for for an audience
there would be nobody else around he
would just have them judge it
and he would literally stop production
or not go forward
because of that little weird little town
and if harvey weinstein is
horrible as his integrity is but the man
was genius when it came to business
and how things work and how to get
things made and sold things that weren't
necessarily the most popular thing if he
can do that
i can at least go sit in the theater and
watch
how the audience reacts to it even
though they're not the people that we're
talking to the most because they're
going to give you some information
you'll never heard about
i've sat in a movie theater just
recently in writing pennsylvania which
is like the middle of nowhere
but also i went um it was somewhere in
tennessee and i can't remember
the the area but um these people they'll
stay outside the movie theater for an
hour you don't get that in a city
they're like that was nice and they're
out so you don't really get as much
talking even in indie
in indie theaters in a city they leave
much quicker but i'm saying i was just
sitting there with my popcorn just
listening i'm tall
and scott does this uh the director i
work with he actually
goes and talks to them and asks them
questions and he brings me back
information
i didn't hear before because his
questions kind of sparked it so everyone
like in my team my production company
the audacity we kind of
have that mentality like hey go to the
movies please like
my goal eventually is to make sure
everyone on my all my staff
has an amca list like you can go see
three movies a week without worrying
about the cost like it's like you know
these companies have gym memberships
that they give
to the employees i want to give you here
go watch movies that's something i want
to do
so i encourage them go to the movies
take time off to do that because it's
necessary but also
don't just leave after stay for the
credits of course we respect our
industry but then also listen
stay in the lobby a little bit see what
people are saying because that teaches
us
far more than film school an audience
teaches us because that's who we're
that's what we're here for we are we're
here for the audience
so how can you really communicate to an
audience with this idea that you have a
vision but you
you've never really heard an audience
respond to something that you know
what you thought the response would be
let's hear them out
no matter how obscure their area is no
matter how city they are how cool they
are
like those guys that we're like the mom
jeans those are the guys you want to
hear
respond about your little indie like
that's the guy's going to tell you some
truth so yeah listen to him too
everyone listen to everyone
i don't know what excuse me no no
does a project have to have distribution
before you will
take it on as a producer no um i know a
lot of producers that do that
where they only work on a project if it
has distribution or interest
me i'm not big enough to do that and i
don't think i would do that anyway
because there's a lot of times where
our industry once something goes
and pops off everybody runs to that
right
but in like the art of war if everyone's
running and looking over here what's
over here like you know
so if you don't have distribution it
might just be that your
project is just not good enough or it's
a gem
and everyone's looking over here but
guess where they're going to be looking
at next
at this gem that you just found so i
think that even at the highest level
um the producers that don't have that
rule they find those gems and i mean
that from a place i'm not gonna like
i don't wanna name drop but there's a
very specific producer right now like
she's like at the top
and she does that she finds these gems
she meets these directors that like
sundance and she's like what are you
working on
send it over you know like this guy's
weird guy at sundance and
he makes the best like he makes the next
thing that people are looking at and
then you'll see 18 of them pop
up the next year and we stay in that
moment but who found the first
one and that only happens if you find
those things that don't have the
attention so no
as a producer i don't have that rule i
do think about
distribution though early on like i said
like if it's i'm reading a script
and i love it but i'm like who is going
to buy this
like i have to to to dig into that
and that doesn't mean i'm not going to
take it on but i do have to manage
expectation
of the of the writer or producer i mean
a writer or director or whoever is a
part of it so far
and then also say like hey guys like if
we do this
one thing this is going to feel bad
creatives right you're talking to
creatives
this is going to feel bad but if you
make this one change i can make
a whole lot of people see this because i
could probably get this distributor
if you don't make the change i love it
so much i'll work on it but
understand if your goal because remember
we talk about i always ask them first
what's your goal in this where do you
see this going if they're like
oh i just wanted to be in theaters and i
just want this well now we got to have a
conversation this is not going to
probably make it to theaters
and then they just slump down but if you
make this change
i'll have a better chance to get into
theaters and now we're having a
conversation with a creator that doesn't
want to make any changes
but now they're more motivated because
they want their goal is to get people to
see it or their goal is to get to
this distributor or to get on netflix or
whatever it is so yeah
i think it's important to remain open
but mindful of distribution
is that change usually always um include
adding a name talent to the main
character no
jason bloom ruined that no i love jason
bloom um
no it's right now if you're at a big
budget level you definitely need a name
to person you need somebody that people
recognize because
you're going to get people to watch this
everywhere
so it's all about the marketing and
nothing else like you just have to
show things people like they want to see
a sex scene they want to see a beautiful
woman they want to see a guy that they
recognize
give it to them but if you're in a
independent space right you're in a
place where you're bringing
some art you're bringing something that
connects with this audience or that
audience
there's other motivations here it's not
just the glitz and the glamour it's not
just the color
there are other things that can make
something go like look at blair witch
i mean that thing went nuts and why did
it go nuts you learn that and then you
can apply to other things but
those those moments in time where all
the rules
that people tell us well you need a name
actor you need this we've seen
we've seen things happen without it
there is there is it's not an anomaly
it's only anomaly because it happens so
feel far between because people aren't
taking chances
i recently spoke to someone um that is
i won't say the name of the company but
they're pretty
everyone knows the name of this company
and they said
i love this project but i have to be
honest i would be scared to distribute
it
and i was like what like i'm this little
producer you're telling me you're scared
i'm not
but they have to be because their job is
literally
to make sure something sells they're not
creatives they're not i mean they could
be but that's not their job their job is
to only make sure something sells
now their next film they make a decision
that head of acquisitions or whatever it
is
they make a decision it doesn't sell
guess what they can get fired
so understanding like there's a job here
that's on the line
the only reason they're telling you no
is because something doesn't necessarily
push us forward so then go back to the
big dream having the ability then
like a harvey weinstein to be able to
find that little gem
and market it in a way that connects
with those niche audiences that connects
with those people that care about more
than that
so it's not just a named actor it's like
tugging on this heartstring
tugging on this political like salacious
moment that we're all experiencing
we're arguing about this let me just
drop a line in the trailer that tells me
that we're going to deal with this
controversial thing and now i want to go
watch it or whatever it is that you know
we play these games of marketing
and then you watch the film you're like
oh it wasn't really about that but i got
you to come
because i focused on these elements that
aren't
necessarily are only an actor a star
so it is overcomeable but of course
we're still in the age of like
faces and people that we know they drive
people to it it's like i know this woman
and actually even uh
the wife of our executive producer she's
not going if it's not tom cruise
like if it's tom cruise because she's
not she doesn't like going to movies she
likes to watch you know her
you know netflix or whatever but if it's
tom cruise she's getting up and she's
going
so you have to keep that in mind but if
you can afford a tom cruise
the person you think that's going to
bring all these people in is probably
won't so you need that
plus this plus this plus this so focus
in on those other things first
and then try to fit that star into the
budget because and i'm not trying to
focus on tom cruise but if it's not tom
cruise if it's not denzel
they're not flocking for it and also
we're live in a time where people can go
watch tom cruise at home now
or denzel at home or will smith at home
or angelina or whoever
so that's not going to get them out to
your movie necessarily
so now you got to think of the other
elements i think it's making this work a
lot more hard
to really dig in and see what people
want so
it's a curse it's a moment where
everybody's like exhausted like what do
they want
how to sell this but also it's like it's
a blessing it's like we get to grow
in this moment as filmmakers as
storytellers like i'm not going to
depend on a star
i'm going to depend on how i'm going to
connect with that audience in such a way
if i just get a good marketing team to
show that i've
got that connection my movie's going to
get seen
and then you got to add in all the other
glitz and glamour of like commercials
and things so pna
yeah so it's a lot a lot of elements too
but the actor that big actor that makes
them come
has been diminished because we're kind
of going into the next era of
ensemble cast interesting stories that
connect to this group of people
you know we're kind of moving away from
that because we years ago we moved into
the age of realism
so when you got realism happening in
real life it's not all about one person
so how can you bank a whole movie on one
person unless you're just like
the whole world's in love with them and
how many stars can we actually say right
now
everyone's in love with i mean it's like
it used to be just
that was the world like even growing up
watching old movies is like
it's just certain people humphry pole
cars right right
but where is our humphrey right now
where is
our audrey hepburn my favorite
um where are those people that just
people just are they fell in love with
our hollywood sweethearts our america
sweethearts
where are they they're they're now
getting into that phase of they're also
producing like brad pitt or you know
like it's it's different like
they're getting into new era and then
this newer era of actors and such
they're an ensemble cast they're getting
known on
like it was this actor i was like how do
they have such a big social media file
i've never heard of them
and then someone told me oh they're on
that show on netflix i'm like what
but that girl's not gonna sell a movie i
didn't know who she was so so
so many others but if you found that gem
on netflix you have this huge following
you got people following social media
engaging with you
but you can't sell a movie off of her if
you're releasing in theaters
so the people that people are like
attracted to right now are
influencers that they can watch for free
on their phones
so how do we overcome that we can't only
focus on the actor anymore we have to
focus on connecting with them and
something they care about
and that takes a lot more work sometimes
do you think the reason we don't have
the ava gardeners the humphrey bogarts
audrey hepburn's is because there is too
much realism and now we know about
everybody's personal life for better or
worse
because that's become part of the
tabloids at the supermarket and we just
can't resist
oh wait oh this hap oh i just have to
see this really quickly
and it ruins it because then we see
they're just like
they're just like us yeah it's like um
it's a
good and bad thing to know that they're
just like us like you know you see in
the magazine they're just like us they
go grocery shopping
that's fun right but you like oh they're
just like my uncle so and so
that is on like some type of drug or
they're at rehab or they're
making a fool of themselves at a party
and you get to watch it the next day on
tmz it's like
it's the glamour is gone it's not the
same i can't say it's gone it's changed
so it's more like wow you're on tv not
wow
you're perfect that doesn't exist
anymore um
so again with the information age that
we are in
that's information across the board but
that also is a lot of exposure
and when you are exposed it's going to
either be really good or really bad
that's why people hide themselves so
often we can't be vulnerable because
it's exposing ourselves and you're
exposing something
it's something you don't want people to
see so now we're at the state where
it's people being paid to go find things
that people don't want to see
people are being planted in places to
spark that
uh un unnatural or uh
i don't know just ugly desire that this
person has yeah let me go plant someone
to help bring that
into play this is a weird time we're
living in and then we also have
things like me too that people that oh
they lifted them
on these pedestals and they fell in such
a demoralized disgusting way where
you're like
him i followed him with like i would
watch everything he's in so yeah i think
the masses are a little jaded and i
think
as filmmakers we have to accept that
because so many so often they i mean
they still
and i'm like studios are smart they do
it best right but then they
put someone in a film and they put so
much money into it and they're like
you watch that they just banked on a
star and it didn't work
and they do it again and again and again
so especially in the
independent world we can't make that
decision we don't have the the capital
or the security to even like have a
failure so we have to be really mindful
like
hey let's think holistically about this
let's understand where people are
there's no more wow so-and-so's in your
movie like that's a little less of a
thing
so being mindful yes there are tabloids
there's all these things
that can pull a person down and show us
the realism but also on the flip side
you can also
see some really cool things like how
caring a person is in their philanthropy
or whatever so
so many things about it where they could
just fill out your buddy
but you don't necessarily get really
excited to see your buddy it's a family
familiarity
so let's not act like they're excited to
see this actor they have to be excited
to see your film
they have to be excited about your story
and the only way to connect with
someone's excitement
that is proven at any time is to find
out their why to find out their own
motivation
so again going back to knowing the
masses like what are we being motivated
by right now what are we worried about
and the news does it so well i think if
we watch the news and then figure out
what to write about i think
we'll kind of win because the news knows
all right now they're fearful
let's talk about the taliban all day or
now they're upset let's now bring in all
the negative things that were tweeted
it's like well we can do that too as
filmmakers but we could also give a
respite audrey hepburn audrey hepburn
one of the favorite quotes of mine
that she was proud to be in a business
that gives a respite and
we still can do that even though we're
living in an age of realism and we're
giving real stories we can still let
that person escape from their life
by connecting with their feelings and
that's something that we're
so connected now with social media but
there's so much less of a connection
i remember growing up i knew all my
neighbors and down the street like they
could tell me get off my lawn i'm
telling your mom and i knew they were
really serious now like my son i don't
know the neighbors down the street they
would
yell at him i would never hear about it
so we're less connected but more
connected
it's an odd time we're trying to figure
out where we're at we're
even trying to figure out what what the
sexes are now it's so many things
but we as filmmakers have a great
opportunity to capitalize on that in a
way that's not
just for the sake of oh let me
capitalize off of that and make some
money off of it
like some movies that found um a
controversial thing and made a movie but
then it failed
because it wasn't authentic what is what
is it mo what more that can you give
because the tabloids already give
the salacious like drama there's reality
shows that can give them drama so what
else are you giving them
where they can take away and we can do
that in a way that no one else can
film is still i think by far the most
comprehensive easiest way to connect
in a two-hour frame and then the story
is over tv is amazing
but your story can go on forever so
you're going to lose people you're going
to gain people
but film is like hey here's the story so
what are we giving with that story
we can give so many things so just being
mindful of those other things that we
can give
and then we're able to get there in that
place where people are watching our
films and people are
celebrating our art and we're getting
more chances and all that all that
though
starts with the why like why the
audience likes something where they're
at so
yeah be mindful of the times
we got to make sure we start with the
this is my line got to start there
yeah it's like give that was a give the
mouse a cookie give the mouse a cookie
he's gonna want some milk
is that the oh i haven't read that one
yeah it's like a children's book if you
give a mouse a cookie you give it is
that what it is yeah give him a cookie
he'll want some milk and then it's like
after you get the milk and then the
mouse wants like a napkin it's like it's
like this whole little thing okay
it's a children's lesson but we all need
to know it like don't give that mouse a
cookie even though it's like well a
cookie's harmless
no because if you get the cookie now
you've established that he can get
something that he wants and not just say
he she like
and it's not even on this on the same
thing as a scandal even in business like
on the business side like all right well
you're going to go ahead and work for
cheap that's great do it work for free
if you're able to do it
but you it's a different establishing
moment it's like when i was in my space
of like i'm gonna work for
free and go make money in production for
events i would say this
you know what for you i'm gonna do this
now normally i wouldn't do it but i'm
just i believe in your project so much
now i was not lying but i had no other
options
right but you can't have that that that
um posture
like when you have strong beliefs in who
you are and you keep that morality solid
in your lines
you can present something and it's not
being fake it's just knowing where
you're going
you might not have anything right now
but if you go to that table like please
i could have some more you know like
then they're going to treat you like
that and then when you've grown they're
still going to treat you like that so
come to the table like you know what
for you i'm going to do it for free or
for you i'll do it cheaper for you
i'm going to do a little bit more work
than i normally would but
you have to communicate that as the
anomaly so they don't think they want to
feel
let them feel like they're getting a
treat not like this is what it is like
this is just how it is
so i think it's our posture
all aspects but our posture is motivated
by our confidence and our morality and
our
you know this is my line like having
that established and it's hard but again
going back to
building your person building your
confidence building who you are
building the your sphere of influence
building those things before you build a
career is great
now a lot of people can't do that
they're thrown into it they're a disney
star or whatever but that's why you see
so many disney stars
have these horrible like young
adulthoods but there was nobody around
to keep them in that space
and let them know who they were before
they went and played a character and i
think the ones that
actually do succeed and you see them
like thriving life they always say oh my
family
kept me grounded i knew what i was
coming into my dad always told me
don't accept people treating you this
way or whatever it is like it's
something there
that they were holding on to so we can
apply the disney character
uh not just disney but young just uh
child actors
apply that to your life as an adult and
you really will learn a lesson it's like
i gotta hold on to who i
am i gotta hold on to my values i gotta
hold on to my
my heart no and never waver from that
and and
once you make that decision i don't know
what it is about the universe it would
attract
the counterfeit the dangling of the
carrot
because i i get approached by so many
things that i'm just like
and these people like i didn't even got
approached by that i'm like well maybe
because i just
i have a heart no and for some reason it
wants to test it it's like the universe
is testing their heart no
and i've been tested in every single
time i've lost money because of it i've
lost jobs because of it
but where i am now is so much more solid
the
integrity that i've operated in is so
much more solid my foundation i've built
and also
i believe that people that work with me
they'll work with me for the rest of
their lives
because i'm coming from a space that i'm
coming as a whole person i don't need
them to come to me
a certain way for me to feel like i'm a
whole person i'm already that
and that's a relationship technique but
it's a technique that you can apply to
any relationship not just marriage or
whatever
you can apply it to work so come as a
whole person
even if you're the guy that just wrote
his first script you don't have you're
living in your car like sylvester
stallone
salon went in that room and said no i'm
going to do this i'm going to play the
character
how did he do that he was homeless
because he knew what he had he knew who
he was
so sylvester stallone can be rocky when
everybody told me you can't
so can you hold on to your heart no the
thing that you know is part of your
your future you can hold on to that even
in a moment where it's like uh i don't
really have any power in a situation
you don't have to come up with bravado
but you could come with confidence and
you could walk in the room like i'm the
cheapest person here
i got all these cheap clothes i just
finished the script this morning
i was riding all night or whatever it is
i don't have this i don't have that i
just
have like three dollars in my bank
account and walk in that room like the
person that you're growing to be or that
person you've already seen because if
you have
a desire and something you already saw
something for the future
walk in the room like that and that's
any room and you will have different
responses
than these people that uh gave the mouse
a cookie and then he asked for milk and
then this and then that
like stay right there just keep your
cookies in your pocket
and and don't go forth in a space where
you're wavering on those
those non-negotiables and to have
non-negotiables you got to have
confidence
to have confidence you have to have
proven yourself in some way
to you not to someone else so if you've
proven that hey
i think i'm talented i think i can deal
with people i can do this i can do it so
stay in that space you're you're
talented somebody tells you you're not
that doesn't mean now you got to do
something that they
want you to do to show on your talent
you know you're talented so have that
posture having that posture has
helped so many people that i've seen and
definitely helps me and i think that's
that's the way whatever your entry point
is if you hold on to that your entry
point
will be pure it won't be something that
you gotta look back on like man i had to
do such and such to get in this industry
you can
actually say you know what i i did it
right and i
got positive responses because of my
confidence because
confidence will bring the most powerful
person at your doorstep
because if you believe in you they're
like whoa what is it that i'm missing
here let me see what she has you know so
i think confidence is a big part of that
having those non-negotiables
before we got started with our interview
we were just talking about
hiring people and you know people
reacting to the word no people reacting
to the word yes
you talk about that and and what that
means to you
yeah it's a little practice that i have
adapted and still
i think i play around with it um is to
when hiring someone or working with
someone or
going into any form of partnership or
place where i'll have to interact with
someone
i watch the way they respond to no and
even if i have to kind of strum up this
opportunity where i can tell them no
early on or
even if it's not a no it's like all
right give me a second
be patient whatever it is now in those
early stages you're not going to come
out and say these things you have to be
very very very perceptive
but just see how they react to that and
that is going to usually be a telltale
sign to
something about their character that you
might have to keep an eye on
and i say i play around with it because
i've actually seen this work
where i've never been wrong it's like
okay i saw the way they responded to no
even a year from then they're having a
horrible
situation with a co-worker or cast
member
or this or that and it comes down to
that one thing where i saw
they can't handle the no
or there's something that stirs up in
them from a no
and what i've seen is you know you can
like simplify it to be in childhood of
maybe mom told them no too much or maybe
mom told them
no not enough like ever or um
the teacher kind of was like well
they're a special kid let's let them do
what they want or whatever it is where
you had
freedom to do something that maybe
wasn't the most like healthy freedom
um where you needed some boundaries or
whatever it is um
uh some people are
then able to mature and seek out what
they didn't get
but most people aren't most of us just
aren't that mature it's just
it's what it is so we're we're going to
fall into a space that we were prone to
from childhood even if you don't see it
in certain moments you're going to see
it when things get bad and with film
things are going to get bad at least one
day it's
like the moment of truth like you get to
know people so much
after you film a film with people
everyone's like oh i love you and
where does that happen you work with
somebody for a year and you love them
like
we can work at um i don't know a plant
amazon and
like i don't even know what are kids
names but you don't know anything about
a person you don't have any feelings for
the person but
the feelings are high because you're
very connected it's intimate spaces
there's long days
it's things that are uncontrollable like
weather
and finance and whatever things that you
just can't control
so it um it's going to stir up people
in a a more aggressive way than other
vehicles right so knowing that you need
to know how they respond to no
you need to know how they respond to an
obstacle
and you need to know how they're going
to interact
when they're upset about something or
not happy about something or didn't like
something
and the way that i find that out in a
very limited way
is to early on even sometimes before i
hire them is to tell them no
or wait or i don't really like when you
said that
how do they respond to that like scott
who i work with he's
very much a part of our company the
audacity but also he directed um the
film
um uh the film i last worked on and
he is like the best at i don't really
like that and he's like oh why don't you
like it
that's his response that's awesome it's
not
how dare you it's like no it's okay like
now let's talk i don't like that you
don't like that why
so but if someone's like i don't like i
don't like when you said such and such i
don't really like that idea and they're
like
they get sad that doesn't mean don't
work with them that just means be
mindful that this person
may not be able to take those moments
and you're going to have to have those
moments when being creative
creatives have to feel confident to talk
and they can't be shut down by a no
so there's someone i'm working with now
even like brilliant
but the the nose or when the other
team's like ah what about this i don't
really like the idea what about this
you see them pulling back and kind of
putting a wall up
and digging into that a little bit more
they didn't have those opportunities to
kind of like
show themselves as a kid and be
validated by showing themselves it was
more like stay in your place
not right now not right now no stay here
so when that person starts to feel
comfortable and they say what they were
thinking
i need the team to be mindful now's not
the time to criticize
except what they just said and then
we're going to deliver this a little bit
more softer than i do i would with scott
scott you like no i don't like it all
right why like you know it's it's it's
being mindful of people being careful
with it but knowing that this is going
to be necessary
so if it's necessary for me to tell you
i don't like your idea let's find out
how you react to that earlier than
where i'm like oh my gosh we have a
deadline and this person literally will
not right now because now they're just
having a mental breakdown because they
don't like their idea
because that can derail a whole project
so
finding that out early on in a fun
little way a very easy way that i i
have adapted to my own likes is
yes finding out how they respond to know
or wait or i don't like it
were there any mistakes that you made
with what death leaves behind
that you wish you could have corrected
or
okay absolutely um yeah i made a lot of
mistakes on what definitely is behind
and
and i make mistakes in anything i think
the main one though
um one that i'll i think i learned the
lesson
well enough is to not deviate what i
know is true what i've already learned
um so i made a a concession
for an individual i saw something
but i accommodated it instead of dealing
with it
and i know that's not the way to do
things i know that but i made a
concession because the person was
temperamental and a little sensitive
and that's is something that you adjust
with but that's not something you don't
deal with it's not something you don't
change with or
you know you still have to thwart things
stop them before they grow
and that one decision allow for this
person
to put i guess poison on others
because i figured if i just accommodate
that thing
and make sure i'm building them up
enough or
giving them enough encouragement then
they would be okay
but they were okay with me but if that
you saw something i won't say ugly but
something
undone in a person how do you think
they're going to interact with their
teammates
they're going to bring that to them and
that's something you know as a producer
you're all
up here you're not going to hear the
little the little riddle like the little
sounds the little
murmurs the little complaints you're
going to hear the big stuff and when the
big stuff comes you're like
i could have fixed this by dealing with
what i saw so i think for me the main
the main thing that i messed up on was
not sticking to something i knew was
true
because i was trying to accommodate a
person you have to
that's the thing about being empathetic
right like you're empathetic
but that doesn't mean you change your
movements that means you change how you
deliver the movement
so it's like the conversation should
have been had and i should have
put um a i guess like a
a test for moments where i can check
back in
or ask people around him hey how's how's
it going with this not giving them
anything but just kind of seeing
because by time it got to me the one all
the way up here it was like
mayhem and i'm talking about that's one
thing that doesn't normally happen with
my sets because everyone
feels empowered they feel supported but
it's a book called the energy bus
and there's one person that can shift in
energy and you feel it and if you're all
the way up here
you're thinking oh let me get them going
let me give them more
let me make sure they have better food
you know but you won't know where it's
coming from but that's why
in a leadership position we have to make
sure when we see things
we deal with it and we have to deal with
it aggressively and that aggression
though
should have empty empathy with it
because if you're strong without empathy
you're a jerk
so be strong though first with empathy
and now
you're a leader now you're fixing a
problem now you're
the person that's going to remove the
energy that is lacking or
or bringing negativity and even that's
hard for that person
should do it with care but now everyone
else is taken care of because you can't
think about the person most you have to
think about the group most
so i'm thinking about my whole team that
energy would not have been given the
concession or the past
i would if i was thinking of the whole
team in that moment and not the person's
feelings
i would have dealt with it it would have
been out and a few people were hurt by
that person that wouldn't have been hurt
if i dealt with it differently
and it wasn't even a lesson like wow
that's how you do it it was like
something i knew
but i made a deviation and and that was
the outcome so
thank goodness it the end of it you know
everyone that dealt with it i mean we
had like meetings about it we had
this is after the film is over um we
dealt with it and it was kind of like
almost like a
support group and i'm laughing because
it's like oh my gosh how this happened
but yes that that person definitely was
a negative energy and they were removed
halfway through production but they
didn't even have to be
there i could have just continued on
caring about that person off the set
and that's what i would have done
different when should a producer quit
their job
whatever their day job was or night job
was to focus on
being a film producer entirely when do
they feel like or when do you feel like
that's a safe transition yeah um it's
really hard to be
safe when transitioning from something
of structure or
stability to being a producer um
unless you're going to you got a job you
were hired
at a studio or something like that it's
a hard thing but if you're coming from
the independent world and you're like
i'm about to venture out and just do
this
it's really hard to establish a safe
thing i think wisdom is the most
important thing
wisdom within a place that could be very
dangerous um for one
whatever your profession is or whatever
you're making your money in
see if you can continue making that
money while still doing it and if you
say i can't
find out why like is it a money problem
a time problem
is it a capacity problem because it's
gonna look so green on this side
of like i get to live out my dreams and
i even work with somebody right now
where they're like i just can't wait
till i can
quit my job and i'm like yes but then
this that seems so perfect even when
they kind of said we're stressed they're
like this is great i'm like yeah but
when this is your thing
and everything is dependent on it that
stress is something that you're going to
experience higher than your job
because there's no there's no net there
so just be aware of
why like why is it that i feel
that i can't do my job still and do this
so then come up with a plan so for me i
was doing events and i never had that
cushion
i always had i don't know living on the
dangerous side i always had contracts
and i didn't have a job i always had
that but you know with events
you get that one client that just keeps
hey can you do this can you do that it's
great
so i had that but those clients i
couldn't do
you know i produced a lot of big events
and then i also
did personnel management for like u.s
open just to give an
idea of the high level um amount of
pressure or
importance of me being there right so to
remove myself from that
i had to save money and that money that
i saved was enough if something went bad
i could have money to exist on before i
went
and did something else to make some
money like if that that's money and
that's different for everyone you gotta
really take an account of what your life
is
i live way below my means always that's
something i learned from my dad being
this jamaican man um but what do what
what do i need to survive and what do i
need to survive for six months
six months like if something went bad i
didn't get to the sixth month
i didn't have no nest egg that big but i
was able to have like a solid like say
four
put away because four months i'm scrappy
if things go bad i can find some money
in four months you know so put some
money away to where
if something went bad it didn't work out
don't have a safety net where you're
going to quit but have a safety net
where you can still figure it out and
you don't have to just
fall apart and then go work in a soup
kitchen i don't know it's something you
know
um so that and then figure out um
who is your support system in this next
venture because
a lot of times we think again it's so
green on that side where i'm going to be
having this
wonderful career but it gets really hard
and
it's not the same support as a job
people like oh my boss is this my boss
is that this manager
but there's a manager there there's
somebody that manages you
there has been teams of people that sat
and came up with a plan of what you're
going to do today
that's an employee now you go into the
other world
where now you got to figure that out you
need a support system of people that you
can bounce ideas off of that can
hold your head when you're crying you
know there's so much more that needs to
be built into your life that isn't
necessary for a job where
as americans you know like that
industrial age really put us in that
that
employee mindset which is fine like
that's how we survived all these years
but now as we're venturing out to things
in business
film is a business so you're going to
film you can't just think oh i'm a
creative you're also a business because
you're going to have to do
something you're you're now a commodity
at the job your time is your commodity
you're
asking can you pay me for this amount of
hours now you're saying
hey i have to build my art and build
myself to be a commodity enough where
someone's going to pay me to do it
and that's a whole new world and you
don't know it yet unless you're coming
from business to business like if i was
you know this awesome business person
that's why some people you see like ava
du renee like she kind of crossed over
and she's like whoa
she's this huge uh director out of
nowhere it's like no she was doing this
thing
already so if you haven't already been
doing it understand you're going to come
into it
at an elementary level and don't have
these ideas of grandeur like oh i don't
i'm good like no you're not
it's okay so have a very strong support
system
read a lot and i don't mean just reading
film books read for something that's
going to feed your mind
because times are going to get harder
than what you can imagine
and that's not like doomsday but it's
like you're going to experience
some very new things that's hard new is
hard so if you're experiencing new
things you need some truths to hold on
to in those moments
so read me personally i read a proverb
every day every single day every proverb
and i'm always trying to read some type
of book even if it's like i mean our
time like sometimes i'm not sleeping so
i'm not reading as much
like hey i could just grab this little
john maxwell book and just read a page
okay and then go back to what i'm doing
you know so just feeding yourself
you don't need to feed yourself as much
when you're an employee mindset but you
need to feed yourself when you're in a
position where either business ownership
or
where you're now a commodity you have to
feed yourself and feed yourself you're
getting rejection you're getting this
you're getting that
and remember the things that cause
someone to quit
is not usually their ability it's
usually something that is happening that
they can't overcome so let's go ahead
and build your up
yourself up to where you're not going to
quit when things get hard because things
will get hard
and then outside of that timing is
everything
like let's say i don't know the whatever
the p the position is that you have
know the timing of it like if you can
you hold off for one more year
when you and you hold off one more
you're able to execute this plan of
saving and such without
as much stress you know that's the
timing of that or
okay you have a film idea great have you
written it yet
have you talked to the people that are
going to be helping you in this next
moment if you're going to be producer
do you even know what project you're
going to be working on i left fully
when i was ready to produce my own
feature i was producing things and doing
this it was like
pulling me all types of directions and i
lived like that for years
it was hard but be okay if you're in a
hard space and you're like
this is too much good because when
you're ready to step
out that too much when you take off one
element you're gonna feel like i can do
this even more than someone is just like
right off the bat like i'm quitting i'm
going but everyone's different some
people just like
throw their cares to the wind and jump
into it but they're jumping into
something that already exists
so where are you going so yes you're
ready to go that's great
uncomfortable uncomfortability is a sign
of change you need to change if you're
uncomfortable
and i think that's that's our what we
are created with
i believe in a creator so what you were
created with to
say there's something in me that is so
uncomfortable in this box
i gotta get out good but be prudent
about it
talk to people find out where you're
going before you just throw everything
away
and say i'm done some people tell me wow
you're so courageous you're so bold like
how did you just
how did you do that especially because
when i was leaving that world
my one of my clients offered me double
my salary
for an event and that's where i knew i
had to go
because i could have just been like oh
more money but if they offered me double
and that entire time they weren't paying
me double
i realized that i will only be paid even
though i was great
i will only be paid by someone how much
they the least amount they can do
for my worth but when i got into film
now i'm creating my own
entity now i can go ahead and say i'm
going to make it what it's worth i'm
going to add the pieces together to make
this worth something
not someone telling me my worth is this
and then saying you know what i'm going
to subtract you know i'm going to add
so i think it's really important to just
really know where you're going to
um be an uncomfortable good but just
know
how long can you handle that
uncomfortability is longer than you
think
and don't think that it's wasted time
with this job
because it's building something with you
that's going to be applied in other
things
i don't care what the job is you can be
working at starbucks a hot dog stand
whatever
because that juggling perspective of
starting something while doing something
or
even just having that ability to dream
while you're under that cloud
that's strength being built and that's
like strength you can pull from later on
in this residual income like where it's
like hey the things that i went through
in that time period of kind of doing
both i'm able to really pull from that
moment when i'm like this is too much
i'm like wait
i don't have to do an event tomorrow i'm
good you know like so it's something
again confidence
built based in work i already overcame
things i already have done those things
while trying to get to the goal yeah but
then i also was doing this
i know i could do something i can i can
make things in my own hands i can
achieve greatness i can do these things
so do that prove it to yourself do a
confidence check like you know like
am i confident enough to do this and
then go off and do it and and
then it's like without refrain without
looking back with no second
like you know like this is my plan b no
only have a plan a once you get there
but don't
hear people say that and be ignorant to
the fact that they got there
you can't start it like no plan a like i
mean no plan b
i'm only playing a but wait hold on how
do you get there
you have to be proven you have to be
wise you have to make decisions you have
to make plans and then you can
cast all that away and jump in with both
feet
what's your process six months before
production three months
two months a week um it varies the
process of
six months three months two minutes etc
it varies but
i would say here's pre-production right
for a producer that's like the first
big milestone starting pre-production
because you're working way before
you're the only one but you're working
before pre-production because the
official
pre-production starting you have a team
involved so there's a lot more money
involved
for pre-production but before that
you are focusing on possible issues
before you bring other people on and
those possible issues first of course
starts with a script
um it starts with where the money is
coming from what their expectations are
what they like and don't like how they
want to be communicated to
um it's establishing what your identity
is as a project
what kind of people are going to bring
that together just kind of game planning
on
where you're about to go is going to be
putting pieces together but you can't
put pieces together yet until you know
the box that you're going to be putting
them in so kind of establishing that box
if that's the
way they put it that's what's happening
six months out
you're establishing a box and that might
take a year
instead of six months but you have to do
it way before you're actually doing the
work
way before you're bringing people in
that you're going to lead and ask to do
a job
you need to have a boxer to fit into and
it's hard to do it because
as producers we're not the people that
actually are going to do it
so it's hard to say this is the box now
do your thing in that box
unless you have a true vision of where
you're going
so first things first six months out you
should already have a vision but if you
don't
establish it hardcore because if you're
going to hire a director specifically
some projects you know the director is
already on but you're going to hire
someone to then
lead the way in this beautiful creative
he needs to know
where you're going because then he can
say got it here's my creative i'm going
to fit it into that and we're going to
go in the same direction
because producers and directors oh my
goodness they can
or they can do this and when they do
this beautiful things happen
and usually what i see i take the onus
of that the producer
has to establish a culture a direction
uh how we're going to do this
it has to and it's not saying this is
the way it's going to go saying hey this
is what i'm thinking
this is what i see and see if that
person can bond with that
and then be within that those confines
because
as producers we're the only people that
has a power over that person
and we got to be really mindful of that
power you shouldn't be you shouldn't be
concerned like
putting your power in there because you
don't like what they're doing you know
it's like oh well
they're creative just doesn't make sense
to me today doesn't matter that's their
creative you are hired them that's your
fault
so understanding though before you start
having them work as the leader of that
that set
you need to make sure they know what you
expect where you're at
what the stakes are even like directors
they come in they're not supposed to
think about money
they first have to feel free to create
and feel the free to go
grab 12 wigs for this one actor no you
know
or whatever it is like we we need a
prosthetic do you you know
but understanding the stakes the limits
the boundaries and then telling them
run wild in that space but you know kind
of working on that relationship too
and the reason i say that a lot of
people think of that as
counterproductive
but it's so productive because that
relationship is going to determine
everything else that's like the two
people that make the film happen
and of course there's money and all
these things but the producer and the
director
if their relationship can work it's
balanced with
what the film can do because now we have
an actual culture we have an actual
direction we have an actual thing and
those things don't have to war
they do war in some ways because you're
constantly like oh we don't have enough
money for that or whatever it is
so you have to tell them know about some
things but then if you're already
established kind of a way to move
that can work so much better um and then
three months out
it's pretty much the same thing but
you're kind of like now team building a
little bit
um you might already have like your
cinematographer on
it might be a director that always works
with a particular cinematographer and
that's great
but just make sure you connect with that
cinematographer as well because the
director and cinematographer are the
first people to argue
the first so if they're buddies and
they're the guys that like
man i love their bond you need to be in
that bond you need to take them out to
dinner you need to go hang out with
cinematographer without the director
take him to lunch by himself separate
them for two seconds and then bring him
back together
the reason being again your game
planning
six months from then three months from
then they might have a little spat
and now here you are you've connected
with this wonderful director you know
him
and you don't know a thing about the
cinematographer how can you solve
the conflict and you know nothing about
this person so this woman that comes in
to
film your project and direct the camera
this beautiful cinematographer comes in
and her director is rubbing her the
wrong way
does she come to you is she able to talk
to you about it or does it just
poison your set because you didn't even
think oh i need to reach out to her too
because i see that another mistake
producers make they don't establish
relationships with all the heads of
departments they're kind of just like
with the director and then it's like oh
yeah no like get in there like have some
moments with each of them
know something about them you don't have
to like take them to lunch all of them
separately but do enough and the
cinematographer i think would be
if you're going to focus in it with
someone else focusing with them because
a lot of times these cinematographers
are very technical
i grew up with around a very technical
brother they're not necessarily going to
tell you how they feel unless they feel
safe
it's certain people that like safe or
not they're like listen here this is not
okay
but cinematographers usually have a
certain i mean they don't all
they're not all the same but usually
they have a certain attraction to
technical things
so that's a lot of things the way that
brain works is normally not like
blah blah blah blah blah so i think it's
really important to
connect with the hazard department but
especially the cinematographer
and even if it's not for anything else
you're like this is a waste of time i
have so much to do
connect with them because later down the
line you're really solving a problem
that you're going to be able to navigate
well
and with actual knowledge that you can
thwart it and get rid of it and bring
those guys back together and i say guys
because i'm you know i just say guys for
guys girls whatever
bring them back together in a way that
is good for everyone because it's almost
like when cinematographers and directors
have a moment it's like mommy and daddy
are arguing like you know
for the cast and crew like this is
uncomfortable so you got all these
people
under these two people and they're all
taking directional cinematographers
talking to these gaffers and these grips
and whatever
the director's talking to the actors and
this and the upm and ad like
all this stuff is happening from their
hands make sure you know these
these people are with you you're with
them you've already
learned a little bit about them you've
hung out with them a bit so when
something happens
if something's happening down here on
the lower levels
above the line or below the line you
know all right let me i know
how to handle this with my heads because
you can't lead everybody
but you can lead leaders so make sure
you're hiring people that are leaders in
your head positions not just the person
that's best
the key makeup artist or the key hair
she might not be the best make up her
hair she can lead a team
she can communicate to the ad she knows
how to verbalize her
issues and hear something and not be
offended but also just make a quick
change
not be destroyed under pressure but the
girl that
or the guy that is like the one that's
working on the main actor
they're the best in the room but they
can't work with anybody they can't leave
anybody so they have their little their
little task but connect with that key
connect with that person and when hiring
them make sure that you know
that person can handle the pressure of
the job not just the work itself the
pressure of it
so i think that's another thing when
you're hiring that crew
um ask questions that are beyond just
technical or
straight to their particular little
world
ask them about them and you'll be
surprised people will talk about
themselves and you're like oh
i don't think this is going to work
or hey you know what i'm going to bring
you on as a makeup artist i'm actually
having someone else
gonna be the key but i want you to soar
and do a great job and you know whatever
you're gonna do so yeah i think it's
really making sure you're establishing
culture establishing that box but really
digging into your heads like your
department heads really need to be
established not only and they are clear
on the vision they're clear on
the the task at hand and they feel
motivated and all those things they
understand a project
but also that they understand they're
about to lead a team
and this is the way i lead i let them
know i don't want any egos on my set
i don't want any let me tell you about
yourself type stuff like no
this is the way we this is where i lead
this is where i'm gonna treat you
this is my expectation for you going
forward somebody messes up have some
grace with them
communicate that to them if you need
assistance and you need backup
use me as a bad guy you don't have to be
it i tell them that all the time
let me be the bad guy you can even say
so rachel's putting the pressure on me
like
it's fine i'm fine being that person in
that way the bad guy
in that way but it's like so often we're
we're only thinking in pre-production or
going into pre-production we're thinking
of i got this in my schedule i got my
checklist there's so many checklists
online now that you can like oh
check check check add to that checklist
people skills
check i understand my head's a
department check
i understand their motivations check add
those things because those are the
things that
something can fall through and just not
go well it's not just because you didn't
have enough funding
it's not just because your lead actor
was in an accident that happened to a
friend of mine just recently
it's those those moments where the team
just something happens
and now they're not able to create the
best or they're just not able to work
together at all
so i think we had a youtube comment from
someone
that said like and make sure that it's
not just a team of people that all know
each other and then you're the new
person
because if somebody turns and there's
like cancer and then
somehow that's then now you're the odd
person out you know what you're saying
i said um that's so true uh familiarity
is not the
goal it's um do you fit into the culture
of the set
so when you hire people like you know
especially hiring a director is like
well these are my guys
you need to meet those guys before you
say yes meet them
and then i would say integrate integrate
integrate because if that these
particular people
are working together and they're
they have a certain way of doing things
and
that's great but they've maybe worked on
it
on a commercial or a short they haven't
been on now this is a group of people
that did five features together
what do you need me for what's your
goals what like let me see if i actually
do actually work with this like is this
who i want
on my set is this how oh i want to
present to this executive producer or
whatever
um but when you see that a lot of times
it's because they worked shallow enough
to where they stay
in a sound peaceful place for just long
enough to do this movie you're about to
hire them for
and when they get to the stress of this
feature it's going to dissipate and i
was on i was a
d on a project that happened on i was
a.d and usually ads are like kind of
like the the odd man out because you got
to be like
the yelling the yelling director right
so you kind of be you're not part of the
crew
that work together you're just there
just you know do your job
and these guys you thought they were
like brothers when they were hired
guys and girls are just guys you know
brothers sisters um and
by i would say week three of the
production
the extreme of the emotion in that room
because something went wrong
was only because they knew each other
like brothers and there was no one else
there to balance it out
so it fell apart the project i only
think was finished
i had to leave i had to go to another
project but it was because they
they're coming into things and it's not
to say you can't do it it's just they're
coming in with so much
history without ever maybe dealing with
you got to find out what's the level of
intimacy
not familiarity great they have fun
together they have beers together
they go to skate parks together i don't
know but
what's the intimacy level of this group
have they offended each other before
and i can ask them that when hiring them
like so have you ever gotten an argument
with each other before or
did you ever disagree with the director
you're talking to have you ever
disagreed with that person or whatever
yeah yeah yeah he did sashimoto ask them
probe they're
like no we're great we never argue come
on these guys
are working together on a film
something's going to come up that they
disagree with
and i need to know you can handle that
and if you haven't handled it yet no
worries
i need to know though how you guys
handle conflict
before i say yes to them being on the
set so i think a lot of times people
like oh great that that's higher was
super easy i got this one guy i got all
these other guys and now i'm done
hold up timeout there might be something
here that you're you're gonna have to
dig into to make sure you're gonna take
all of them
and if it's like all or nothing that's
fine too because i like group say like
yeah it's all of us or nothing
fine but just find out who's the weakest
link who's the negative one who's a
pessimist who's a realist who's the
optimist
and you see if those things work
together so like the optimist is the guy
that's like
the leader of the group you're gonna do
a lot better but the guy that's the
leader of the group
is the pessimist and the realist is you
know just kind of the middle and the
optimus is getting on that pessimist
nerves and the realist is trying to
balance them out and then
it just it's going to explode and you're
going to have to fix it as a producer
how can you fix that with people that
know each other and they don't know you
it's hard so it's not overcomeable
it's not insurmountable it is
overcomable but
you need to be aware of it and make sure
that you're really
not like i said taking it like oh yes
this was easy
easy hired really dig in and it's
another i think it's another level of
hiring when you hire people that know
each other so well
what's been your hardest year in
filmmaking and why
you're going to make me cry no i'm sorry
so
i don't know i'll start the story and if
this is like too much for con like if
it's too much for tv like
just let me know okay but i um lost a
pregnancy
during pre-production oh no so of what
deathly's behind
and it was the hardest
laws even though i've lost people i
didn't realize how bad that was i didn't
even
you hear about people they had
miscarriage and such and mine mine
happened while i was
i was i was put under like i was not
conscious for it wasn't my decision it
was it was one of those things very
traumatic
but um during pre-production i was on
set like you know when i shouldn't have
been right after that but um
yeah it was that was so hard
but i put it away because i had a job to
do
we were about to go into production time
to get moving and i did
i went and moved and we had um
we filmed the dream sequences in what
definitely behind separate from the film
and they're like their own little movie
because it's different it looks
different it's weird it's a dream
we shot it in the sun center studios um
in in aston pennsylvania
and it's very eerie and weird so we shot
them as our own movie
so we like went really hard into it and
this was like a like 2016 or something
and um we shot it and right after that i
had like a little break
from the crazy and i'm talking about
like i went
down like it was like all the pain or
motion that i was suppressing kind of
just came out
and i wasn't used to that level of pain
because
of that type of pain because i don't
suppress things people stuff comes up i
deal with it
but that was different it was like a
whole nother heart string that was
pulled so
that was really tough and then getting
back into production that's where some
things had happened with
one person kind of destroying some of
the the synergy or whatever you want to
call it the the culture the
the caring nature of the set was kind of
disturbed by a person and i had to fire
them
during that time um there was a producer
that was
kind of helping us on some business ends
that kind of did some shady things i had
to get rid of them
it was like all these things are really
hard to deal with for anyone
but i was in this really bad space like
and i don't mean bad like i was
depressed but it was like my heart was
like burst open like it was very much an
open wound
and i knew it and i communicated to my
inner circle in the in the group like
you know like the director knew at that
point they didn't know when it happened
they knew when i had to go back to
hospital because i had complications
from the surgery
during production i was like in the
hospital on my computer and they're like
man put the computer down like it was
like
crazy time and then in the same time i
got to fire someone that was
really important to the production and i
had to get rid of a relationship that
would have made distribution easy
because he was shady like stuff like
that happened during that time so i
think
that year of pre-production
was not even though that was the moment
that wasn't that year wasn't the hardest
it was
while we were in that lull and then
coming back into production and
finishing the project
it was so hard because it was really
it's just the hardest thing to do
to finish a film a feature-filling film
is the hardest thing to do on in our
industry right
but then to be dealing with some of the
hardest things i dealt with in life
on the the side of my husband and i
losing a child like that was
really hard and then like other things
that pop up you know these
you know um draining situations that
have nothing to do with the
the movie but it has to do with the
people making the movie and then
things like being um aware of
and i say shady i mean like they were
doing some bad business
and i had to distance myself from that
um
so all these little things yeah that
made it the hardest year
um and i think we all grew from it
myself included like where we would deal
with
we were dealing with a lot i mean there
were deaths in we had someone in our
production die right after
someone that's in the movie so it's hard
for me to watch the film because he
passed away
and we had um a member of the crew their
grandmother died we had my a.d had to
drop out during production during the
same time
because she had a a family um
death and different little things like
that had nothing to do with the film
but those things that come up is like
are we going to
lose because of something that's not the
loss like we're going to make the film
right like we're going to keep going so
we just had to
it was a moment of huge perseverance
i'll say that and it was
big perseverance like big hurdles to get
over and it was like
one of those things where like you know
you get and you're like ah it was never
that it was like all right another one
another one another one while still
having a very personal like emotional
wound so that was that was hard and
overcoming that though
lets me know on this little film
the things that we went through and
growing leaps and bounds and getting
through and now having a theatrical
release and
you know all the things that you just
can hope for we we achieve that with all
this
hopefully all that won't happen on the
next one right but also we know we can
handle it
so when things happen which they will
when things pop up or
uh things happen to us we've already
proven we can overcome things that are
really difficult and
and not in like you know you go through
something that's hard and you go to
something else you're like whoa that was
nothing no i know this was something
what we dealt with so if we can overcome
that we can keep going if i can keep
going if i can remain a place of i can
still encourage someone that day
when i just cried all night in my two
hours that i could have got some sleep
i can get through anything anything so
there's no project that i can't
confidently say
to an investor i'm going to make this
film and i'm going to get this outcome
because if i said that on this one and
we got the outcome
i could do that on anything and that's a
that's another level of confidence that
doesn't happen without adversity
so if you achieve something in a moment
of darkness
how much easier is the light how much
easier is sunrise like just you know
we've got we've gotten through it so we
can do it again we could do it again we
could do it again
so in those moments of weakness or in
those moments where things are going bad
i know that i'm not going to crumble
because in the time where i should have
in the moments i had the more crumbling
moments i brought it back together and
we kept going and that had a lot to do
with the people i was working with
the team that was created and why that
team worked and why
they were able to like latch on and like
lock arms with me and move forward
when we just lost somebody we cared
about you know like those things is
something
that can't be diminished in any sense of
the word that's why certain people from
what death leaves behind
that are also in my company now like the
audacity and it's our company
it's not like my thing and i'm just
putting you in little pieces like
it's ours because we went to war
together so now we can go ahead and make
these videos and we can
we do all these little projects for
people outside of just a major film we
have two
two shows going on right now there were
one in pre-production in production and
all these things that we're doing i just
feel so confident in room with these
people because i saw them in
bad moments and that's a luxury because
usually
you hire these people you have an idea
of what they'll do and you try to be
prudent but then you get into something
you're like oh
they couldn't handle the pressure i know
these people can they've been
pressurized and they've been pressure
tested
and these these guys aren't going
anywhere so i i think that that's
something that was very important for me
a lot of people we lost and i don't mean
on the death side i mean like people
that just didn't didn't work they
couldn't handle the pressure even though
we
finished the film with them i know not
you're not who i want to go to war with
so i scaled down the the inner circle
but that circle is so solid and i know
we can achieve anything
um going forward and i know i can i can
answer
any promise any thing put in front of me
by somebody with the money
the investor or a network or whatever
because we can overcome
we can overcome anything what about the
best year
best year right now right now is the
best year it's still going
um and it's not just because so many
things are happening it's kind of like
you do something and you got to keep
telling yourself it's going to work it's
going to work
and then you get to that moment where
just it's working you don't have to tell
yourself anymore
and that's actually hard sometime too
because it's like
you've developed this place for so long
where you're like
ah come on it's going to work you're
going to be all right keep going keep
going keep going and then it's working
and like even chad my executive producer
had to remind me like
this is great and i'm like come on just
everybody settle down like you know but
it's like
you get to kind of enjoy it too i'm
still very much in like
you know a fixer mode always but it's
it's one of those things where you can
actually say it
it worked something worked not it's
going to work it worked
and then going to the next thing knowing
you made something work so this is this
right now is the best year
so far yeah so coming off of
what was the worst year now going into
what seems like the best year
yeah for sure for sure and that that
contrast to be the same person in both
is yeah we got a theatrical run yes
we're going to
be on the platforms that i promised our
executive producer yes he's going to
make his return and all those things
that you
as a producer like i got to do this but
the win for me was remaining who i
am in those adversities
and regardless of anything that happened
for me first because i look at myself
first to remain who i am
and then watch the people that i
believed in do the same
we won like there's nothing that can
tell me we lost
because that happened and even before we
got our distribution
and before we like things were finalized
we just it was a sense of
we won because we finished when it was
really bleak at one moment you know so
it's like we
we did it we did that so any other
achievement is like wow this is the
icing of the cake
but we've already made the cake and guys
it tastes good and we can do it again
and again again because we have the
ingredients
and as long as we hold fast those
ingredients i think another thing i'm
really mindful of right now
is we won we built the cake or made the
cake and all those analogies but
we can't forget why it worked we can't
start to believe like i'm
great no no it worked because you did
great things
so continue to do the great things
because i think that's where hubris can
creep in
and we can start thinking like man i'm
good and yes we should think that we
should be like yes we're good we like it
but also like i did good it's so much
more powerful than
i am good it's so much more because
we're people we're not perfect so i
am good is a wavering thing because then
you do something bad and you're like oh
i'm bad
no you're not you did good so even when
you lose if you did good sometimes you
win sometimes you learn
learn from it and i'm stealing that from
john maxwell's a great book
definitely a one of those books that i
recommend but
you don't have to lose you can as long
as you're doing good so if you're
keeping certain things is what you're
doing
know that that's going to work
eventually have that perseverance
but you can't go into something and do
bad practices
and win and then think i'm good i'm bad
you're going back and forth between no
forget i am just
stick to i do and i do this i do that
i do that i do that and that's what i
can say we did that
we did this and it won we did that and
it made a good project
we did that and we were able to achieve
the goals that we set forth and that was
what we could do with the smallest
amount of money
the least amount of resources the
smallest team so imagine what happens
when we're
given the next level and which is what
we're doing right now so
i i'm excited about this greatest year
and um i think the
the worst year has a lot to do with it
though because it wouldn't even feel as
good if we didn't if we didn't win in
that way
you said with the worst year you still
remained
who you are can you explain what that
means yeah um
i think i had i i mentioned this to my
team a lot
um so to say that i had the
worst year and remain who i was best
year remain who i was
i tell my team they the close ones saw
me in an ugly moment
right i cried in front of them and this
is like rachel's
not emotional right i cried in front of
them and
i um mistook something from
one of the like i said the inner inner
circle and i had an ugly moment
and everybody was like oh is she okay
like it wasn't like how dare she i had
an ugly moment of like not cursing
anybody just crying
i cried i had a very weak moment within
this time of the craziness
and um i told them though
i cried in things because i had to tell
them what i was feeling and i told them
and then we talked about it was over so
i remained myself in a place of i could
have got
ugly in that moment because it seemed
like certain things were happening or
maybe i was feeling insecure because of
what i just went through or just i was
off right like i was
experiencing things i wasn't used to
like feeling like less of a woman
because i didn't
carry a child to term or those things
that you don't you don't really know are
happening until
you see something that's wait that's not
me why am i acting like that you know so
that moment though in that moment i
still communicated
what i was feeling to my team which is
what i tell them i need them to do
always i was like i don't care it's ugly
it's something i preach but i did it i
did that and for that reason it didn't
spiral into a big problem it didn't grow
it didn't disturb our way of life
that those ugly moments don't destroy a
team it's because you let that ugly
moment
or you let that ugly thought fester and
things like that so i
spoke to them and we find we did it and
we were dealing we just dealt with
something else in the team
somebody was dealing with something and
i brought that moment up
in that in that meeting you guys
remember when i had the ugly moment
remember the ugly moment that's what we
call it and you're like rachel wasn't
that bad i'm like no
that for me is as bad as it's going to
get me crying
like all that so and i said did anybody
leave me
in that moment no you guys knew i was
dealing with something because i told
you
so all that matters is we can remain the
solid team
we can remain winners if we continue to
communicate
and thwart up any doubt and do those
things that we all preached
and i preached to them to do but
still maintain a level of self
so regardless of that moment i had the
next day it's like all right i'm still
going to get up in the morning i'm going
to work my butt off for you guys it
doesn't matter if i was crying i'm
working
where are you at i'm upset like you know
like i'm going to still do all the
practices that i do
so i worked really hard despite the pain
i treated people with respect despite
the pain i communicated when i had an
ugly moment despite the pain
um i didn't clam up i didn't do the
things that i'm a taurus like you know
like we were stubborn we kind of
i fought that it wasn't stubborn in a
moment i communicated and
and i treated people with respect when
they were treating me bad someone was
trying to swindle me i still treated
them with respect
i let them know what they did wrong and
then i treated them with respect i
didn't demoralize them and spread the
nonsense around and tell everybody what
they did
so yeah remaining yourself is so
important
in good and bad even more so sometime in
good cause like i said the hubris that
pops up when you're wow it's going good
let me go ahead and do x y and z or feel
like that's like wait a minute that's
not you
that's the practice that's the outcome
so the outcome has nothing to do with
the winner
like if you're a winner like serena
williams or whatever like
she just lost uh the us open again like
right
but she won she she went out there she
went through what she went through and
she still performed
she's still i mean second place i mean
goodness gracious for the woman she's
gone through but
she went out she played that's who she
is she's a hard worker she went out
she trained yes this uh body is not what
it used to be because of the pregnancy
but i'm still gonna train i'm still
gonna work hard i'm still i'm not gonna
give myself excuses
or passes to have bad practices or treat
someone bad
and that's what i mean by remain
yourself in the good times and bad times
and i was able to do that
thank goodness in a time when it was it
was clutch
in sports what we say or when it was
sublime or when it was
paramount like it needed to happen where
i remained myself for it to work
so don't let everything crumble and who
you are those those those
identifying factors about yourself when
things get really bad that's
that's why you were yourself that's why
that's why you built these things in for
this moment so don't let it fall apart
or don't let the ugliness of people
bring ugliness in you or
react badly remain who you are